e
e e
good morning today is Tuesday February
18th 2025 this is the New Hampshire
House of Representatives Municipal and
County government committee I am
representative Diane power and the
committee has convene today for the
purposes of public hearings on bills as
well as an an executive session this
afternoon now please make sure that your
cell phones are silenced and please join
us in the reciting of the Pledge of
Allegiance led by representative
bellri I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all thank you so before we begin
hearings this morning I have a couple of
morning announcements so the committee
has convened today at 9:00 a.m. for
public hearings on six bills and after
the public hearing scheduled for 11: the
committee will break for lunch and then
following the afternoon we will go into
executive
session to begin at
1 so to to begin um I just like to
inform everybody in the room that in
order to stay on schedule the chair if
needed will allow up to 5 minutes for
Bill introductions follow Follow by
questions and answers and then up to 3
minutes will be given for
inperson public testimony with
additional time allowed for questions
and answers if the speaker allows the
vice chair who is um at another meeting
right now would be taking keeping track
of the time
um and if we are depending upon how many
pink cards that that we get if the time
needs to be um kept track of somebody
will raise a pink card that indicates
that you should wrap up your um
testimony and if a speaker has written
testimony please indicate that and pass
it along along at either end of the the
tables
here if a speaker also has more
information than they're able within the
time allotted to share with the
committee then please let us know and
follow up by email with um additional
written
testimony and finally as a reminder to
speakers providing inperson testimony
please when you take your seat please
State for the record your name who you
represent in your position on the
bill okay that right
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 554
enabling municipalities to choose
whether or not to place political
advertising on Municipal
property so um I don't have any pink
cards but I do see the prime sponsor
representative
Andress so um she's here to present the
bill to the committee and you could fill
out a pink card afterwards perfect so
good morning and welcome to Municipal
and County
government good morning everyone my name
is representative Louise Andress I
represent Mart County District 5 andova
Danbury Hill Salsbury and
Webster I am here today to present to
you and I'm just going to make it very
short because your decision in end will
be the final
one on T
municipalities making the decision
whether they can have political signs on
their public property now in
1979 the election laws were cified and
brought into being saw that they were in
order now even back in 1979 it stated
there would not be political signs on
public
property whatever happened with that law
is beyond me because it wasn't until
just the last several years that I knew
of anybody was saying you couldn't have
signs on public
property and like in my town up until
last year when we ran for election we
had two locations of property that
belongs to the town where Signs by
anyone could be put up there were
candidates last year we ran into the
state law and it happened everywhere why
all of a sudden I don't know same thing
happened in hill damry all the towns you
can no longer put signs on Municipal
property I feel it's wrong now I only
made a small change in the law I'm not a
lawyer I don't know if it's rooted cor
really rooted correctly or if maybe you
would be willing to change something in
it and make an exception but
municipalities and not the state should
be the
ones that can say political signs can be
put on Municipal
property the state shouldn't be
dictating it and how has ever been this
way all these years I don't know and all
a sudden everybody noticed it or what
the problem is but it has created
problems everywhere because like I said
in Solsbury for years we just had the
signs in the same location nobody ever
said anything and then all of a sudden
the law came into being and uh and now
we're done so you know I'm going to end
it here and if you have any questions I
hope I can answer them and uh I just
hope you will find a way to make it
possible for our 20 134 municipalities
to make the decision whether they want
political signs or not in their town
thank
you thank you representative Andress is
there any questions for
her representative FR is recognized for
a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for presenting your
bill I am curious What entity um told
you that you couldn't put signs
up well we had an incident in our town
last year and they get into the state
law and one the state law said we could
not put up signs anymore on Municipal
property okay thank you that answers my
question further questions
representative Gilman thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question on the public property does
that that include the right of
way any right of way in front of a
building or uh next to a sidewalk or
something like that well in the law it
states that you can't put signs on
public property but you can put them on
the states right of way and so this is
another big issue okay on Route four
where we used to put
signs how far back I mean none of us
ever get into it it was right next to
the road it was considered public Pro uh
the town property but how far back does
the state own and if you could get into
real arguments and get into lawsuits and
this and that but to me it's not worth
it I think we just need
to see how we can make the law better so
municipalities can say you all can put
political signs out on our
property okay thank you
representative majori thank you madam
chair wom and thank you for taking my
question um the word
municipalities um you have in here I
think you spoke to you we might have to
work on the language but who would be
the body deciding this you have
libraries you have select boards you
have town councils would it I are are
you suggesting that maybe this committee
needs to refine that word or are you
specific to the word
municipality okay I think we also need
to refine who in the M municipality has
that
Authority representative Dolan thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh is is there any
restriction uh
considered as a sponsor here uh that the
moderator's role would be reduced
because right now in many cases the
moderator decides if if
signage uh is in the proper place or if
it's inhibiting the voter's access to
the polling place and so
forth yeah I mean if the uh committee so
decided to make an amendment and felt
that the moderator would be the one
because yes in an election the moderator
has total control of everything so maybe
they should be the one that makes the
decision or maybe it should be the
select B you know I'm not sure who it
should be but it
may there has to be a
definite body in the town that makes
that kind of decision thank
you representative Murphy is recognized
for a question thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my
question
electioneering is is that been brought
up with any of the problems that you've
been having in your town people saying
this is election in for the town you
know making one candidate or another
candidate or another position uh what
they're looking
for okay would you repeat that
please the electioneering excuse
me some if you have a political sign
within whatever feat or whatever the
town ordinance says
um you you know is is that been a
problem in your town El you know where
political signs have been
placed how far from the polling place
are they are they
from I'm not sure the answer to
that further questions representative
Gilman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking another question uh would
this apply to a town hall or town office
building um in that my town is a
nonpartisan select board um but
as a State Rep I belong to a party so
could I put my State Rep budget um sign
up on next to a sign that says town
office
building that would be up to each
individual municipality I mean the way
the law is written right now I mean
there are no political signs no place on
public property and if you changed it to
municipalities can make a ruling they
would have the ruling I mean according
to law where signs could be
placed further
questions I have a
question your language says um indicates
May the municipalities and we're
debating who that should be if it should
be a single person or perhaps the
governing body but your language says
may decide the locations assigns in that
municipality do you have a concern
concern that with this may decide that
that might end up with a patchwork of
application across the state and they
for you know candidates running in in
one municipality may be allowed to put
up signs whereas in the next town say
for example State reps would be not
allowed to to put up
signs you see what I'm saying yeah I
know what you're saying okay when this
was originally written we put sh
instead of May and then several people I
talked to thought that we may not want
to dictate what a municipality has to do
so we put may I mean it can be changed
if an amendment is
made thank you additional questions
representative Guthrie yes just quickly
would you believe that in my town on
Election Day that the entrance into the
uh the voting PL
spot which is about oh
maybe 500 yards that there are signs all
the way going in to the voting place and
there's never any a problem with
it well having political signs on
Election Day or any day it's an issue I
realize it's never really be settled
because so many people have difference
of opinions and I know in uh some towns
they feel the the state shouldn't be
coming in on Election Day and telling
them where signs can and can be placed
I've heard that but made statement made
before and in other towns are very
strict I feel it's up to each individual
town if this town wants this they get it
and if another town decides they want to
do something different it's up to
them thank you for your answer thank you
additional questions um representative
stavis
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question my question has to do more
with uh an issue of kind of cognitive
dissonance in the wording of the bill
where um current law states that signs
may be placed with the owner's consent
and your change says the wordss
municipalities may decide to me those
both mean exactly the same
thing that's why I think an amendment
should be made I mean I've been thinking
a lot about this lately and
maybe the amend the way I wrote the the
bill with just changing the part of one
sentence maybe uh under the exceptions M
municipalities could just be put put in
there along with uh you can have signs
on private property along the public
way with owner's permission and but then
I don't know if that answered if that
takes care of everything or not like I
said I'm not a
lawyer representative majority did did
you have a question I do yes thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking another question um in line 14 of
of of this bill but existing language it
says that political advertising placees
that are fixed on any public property
may be removed by the state was there
any
consideration that that sentence in
there may create a problem if the same
organization is allowing it the same
organization May remove
it well if municipalities are given
permission to have C you know make their
own rules on candidate
signs then the state shouldn't be able
to come along and remove move them if
that's what they choose to do
so representative
frock thank you madam
chair and representative I in listening
to the questions and your
responses um I would like to ask you to
clarify my understanding of the statute
66417 which is what you are proposing to
modify um my read on
this
basically does not um include
signs that are placed at or near the
polling
placeat um which may or may not be
considered
electioneering this statute refers to
election signs that are placed
on public
highways um your concern is placement on
Municipal property and I I guess to to
boil the question
down does it refer to signs
placed on Municipal property in
general or is it specifically limited to
signs that are placed near the polling
place which might be considered
electioneering if they were too close to
the
poll well if anything was passed that
gave
municipalities the ability to make their
own rules and regulations they've got to
go by whatever the state law says so
if in the state law it says you can't do
election Heering then this municipality
would not be able to go against de and
make up their own rules and regulations
they're going to have to go by whatever
the the rest of the state law
says thank
you additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much to have a good day thank you
and don't forget your PIN
card
okay so I don't have any other pink
cards for this bill so I will ask is
there anyone present who wishes to speak
on this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do
so is that for this
bill oh okay thank
you okay so seeing none I will close the
public hearing on House Bill 554
excuse me Madam chair yeah yes I just
wanted to um um inform the group uh that
there were three um on the electron uh
remote sign in there were three in
support and 13 opposed thank you
representative Gilman I forgot to um
have you report that out
Pier
just okay
at this time um I do not see the prime
sponsor for the next bill that we have
scheduled to to um here is there someone
from the committee that would like to
introduce the
bill sure thank you
so so um at this time we have
scheduled um a hearing at 9:20 we're a
little bit behind so I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 512 FN
relative to preventing Municipal
Employees from being paid under multiple
Municipal contracts
simultaneously yeah yeah because I don't
see anyone
so thank you representative majori for
introducing this bill to the
committee thank you madam chairwoman
members of the committee thank you so
much for the record I am Jim majori
representing the good people of the town
of Northampton and I'm here to introduce
House Bill 512 FN relative to preventing
Municipal Employees from being paid
under multiple Municipal contracts
simultaneously and I'm happy to take all
of your questions
other
questions seeing none thank you I'm
watching
you so next the chair would like to call
Kristen is it lson
Schultz good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County Government
I appreciate your consideration of my
testimony in support of HB 512 as a
resident of Northampton New Hampshire
I'm deeply concerned about a decision
made over a year ago by our select board
members they approved our full-time Town
Administrator to simultaneously hold a
part-time position in Newcastle New
Hampshire without public
consultation this decision was made in a
non-public meeting denying residents and
taxpayers the opportunity to express
their concerns when residents later
questioned why our town should continue
paying a full-time salary for a Town
Administrator now dividing his week
between two towns they were dismissed as
out of hand the select board argued that
as long as there was no scheduling
conflict it wasn't an issue however as a
taxpayer I find it illogical to
compensate an employee for full-time
work when they are serving another town
2 days a week
especially without any public hearing or
input from
residents over the past year while
sharing Town Administrator we
experienced the resignation of a police
chief a police force operating at half
capacity and most recently the
resignation of a highly respected fire
chief these events indicate that Duties
are not being fulfilled effectively
further upon submitting a 91a request to
both the towns of Northampton and
Newcastle as to the time sheets and
build hours committed I was denied the
right to that
information I asked this committee what
recourse residents have when it appears
that the select board is being directed
by the Town Administrator rather than
providing oversight on issues such as
this opponents May argue that such
decision should remain local and that
legislation is
unnecessary however as New Hampshire is
a Dillan rule state and whereas this law
would impact multiple mun municipalities
I urge the legislature to address this
issue to ensure New Hampshire taxpayers
have
recourse additionally in order to
advance this bill to the house floor I
ask that you amend it to remove the
following sentences any person who fails
to report accept acceptance of a new
town manager or administrator employment
offer while under contract as a town
manager administrator shall be guilty of
a felony uh and this appears uh in both
Section 1 3 and section 23 with a little
variation in the text passing the bill
without the language related to
criminality would still offer New
Hampshire taxpayers essential recourse
and could improve this legislation's
chances of approval in both the House
and Senate I urge you to put forth an
amendment outlined above and vote ought
to pass as amended on this much needed
legislation thank you for your time and
consideration thank you Mr Schultz are
you willing to take
questions uh no I actually have to get
to work but thank you very much for
listening to me and I you it appears as
though you have something written it
could you email that to the committee I
I posted it online this morning and I'm
also happy to leave a copy with the okay
and I can get some copies for the hard
copies thank
you next the chair calls Mr Barrett
Christine
good morning attorney Christina welcome
to Municipal and County government good
morning Madam chair thank you very much
uh good morning members of the committee
my name is Barett Christina I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
school boards Association we are opposed
to House Bill
512 um I went through um the list of
current superintendents and the current
school administrative units that they
are assigned to the district of Siri and
Sullivan have the same individual
serving as their superintendent they are
two Siri is one as school administrative
unit Sullivan is a separate school
administrative unit neither of those
districts have a school they tuition
their students so they have one
individual Ser serving both of those
school districts on I don't even know
maybe a one day a week type of basis so
they we're not talking about somebody
working full-time in one district and
full-time in another District like
likewise the SAU of Winchester SAU 94
and Hinsdale SAU 92 also have these same
individual serving um as superintendent
I believe that individual was three days
in one district and two days in in
another District I'm not sure which
which one is three which one is two but
I know totality he's working full-time
but he's got two separate contracts for
two separate school administrative units
um the same situation in planfield and
Cornish again the same individual um is
is working for both of those school
administrative units part-time in one
District part-time in another District
Alton and Barnstead two separate saus
have the same individual um working um
as as the superintendent in that SAU um
or in those two actually three saus that
actually make sense Alton is one SAU I
believe they SAU 72 and Barnstead I
forget maybe SAU
886 they send their children to prospect
Mountain High School which is a separate
SAU so you've got one superintendent
serving one k through eight District
same superintendent serving another K
through 8 district and then the same
superintendent is serving for a separate
seu but that's their joint high school
so in that situation you're or you're
lining up your policies your curriculum
so on and so forth the last aspect that
nhba would like to address is on page 16
of the bill it says no school
superintendent shall be compensated for
service as a school superintendent under
two a more Contra two or more contracts
at the same time I presume that the
intent of the well I don't want to
presume the intent of the bill but as
I'm reading that I'm wondering if the
gist was two individual employment
contracts and I raised that as the
language is confusing in at least two
circumstances we have here in New
Hampshire the Rollinsford School
District purchases services from the
summersworth school district so the
individual is the is the superintendent
of summersworth that is his title but
rowford pays the summersworth school
district a certain sum of money to have
that person serve as a superintendent
provide superintendent services so
technically that is
a superintendent under two or more
contracts at the same time um and the
same circumstance um applies to Governor
Wentworth which is
sa49 and Middleton I forget Middleton's
um SAU number but the Middleton School
District purchases services from the
governor Wentworth School District so
ultimately the superintendent in the
governor Wentworth school district is
responsible for the superintendent
services in in the Middleton School
District as well too this is not a
concern for these districts um that that
I've referenced they understand that the
individual is working another part-time
gig in a different in a different um
school administrative unit and and they
all seem to be fine with the current
Arrangement that they have so nhba
objects um to the to the provisions um
relative to superintendent contracts we
oppose House Bill 512 and I'm happy to
answer any questions that the committee
may
have thank you attorney Christina
questions representative frock thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um if the bill were amended to
allow for an individual
to be employed part-time
by more than one District would your
organization continue to be opposed um
thank you for the question
representative um as I'm
reading the bill at least as it relates
to the school superintendent
contracts you know it doesn't say
anything about full-time or part-time so
I I don't want to I'm not trying to
avoid the question representative but I
mean our position would be that you know
we would support striking out the entire
language as it relates to school
districts I don't think a clarification
about part-time or for full-time is is
necessary thank you for your response
thank you representative stavis is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair this is a question of the
chair um in the event that a prime
sponsor does not appear to testify as to
the reasons for the bill is it proper
for us to be asking um PE people who are
giving giving testimony if they are
willing to entertain an
amendment thank you for the question
representative Davis my answer to that
would be um yes I I do feel that it's
appropriate because once the bill is
introduced the build belongs now to the
committee and we are present and we
would be the ones that would be um
deciding upon an amendment does that
sound fair
representative Dolan thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my
question if I look at this as a local
issue a one-town
issue uh I'm thinking uh about the
sponsor asking the state to referee
their their one toown issue what is
there anything that you can see in this
bill that would prevent the town from
pursuing
a local warrant article to fix this or
even a citizen's petition to referee
this rather than the state using its
heavy hand to come in and and decide it
for them sure thank you very much for
the question I mean nhba generally not
100% of the time advocates for local
control and a local school district
should be able to hire who they want
within their within their building or
their school administrative unit the
other one of the other concerns that NH
I mean yes so to to to the larger
question nhba has an rejection to a
state law dictating how local contracts
can work you know for a local for local
municipality local school district a
local school administrative unit the
other challenge that I would see with
this with this bill is that the ACT
shall take effect 60 days after its
passage so let's just play this out and
presume this became law and became
effective let's say August 1st the
superintendent that I referenced they
may have three or fouryear contracts so
I don't know how that's going to get
rectified either so I hope that answered
your questions sir thank
you further questions representative
Colby thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um in these many
communities that share a
superintendent
um do you feel it is a financial benefit
for those communities in keeping their
property taxes at a reasonable level
thank you very much uh for the question
representative certainly a school
board's decision on whether or not to
high a part-time or a super or a
full-time superintendent is based on a
variety of factors the economics of that
Community what that Community can afford
to pay superintendent and basically the
size of the school district how many
students you have how many buildings
you're operating we have many I I I
don't even know offand but I would it
would not surprise me if we have
probably a dozen a couple dozen
superintendant that are part-time
because the community is small and in
the district is small um I didn't think
about it during my original introduction
but your question got me thinking about
it representative the other aspect to
the larger policy concern is that um we
have more and more school administrative
units today than we ever have 20 years
ago there were maybe 80 or 85 85 84 885
today we're up to about 107 so every
year there's more school administrative
units that means there's a need for more
school school superintendence we don't
have people going into that field as
much as we used to maybe 30 years ago so
we have more saus and a fewer number of
people to fill those positions so the
idea that an individual and a lot of the
part-time positions they're retired
people they'll work one day a week in
this district and one another day a week
in in another District so so that's I
guess the larger policy concerned with
thank you for your question
representative further
questions so um representativ col's
question is a good segue to my question
would would you be able to briefly
explain to the committee the process
um by which a superintendent is hired in
in that are there hearings is there
opportunity for public input it does one
person um decide the contract the school
board in multi- toown um saus the school
board might be comprised of many school
boards could you just go over that
certainly thank you very much for the
question Madam chair um I can speak to
directly to my experiences conducting
superintendent searches for for school
intive units and then I can speak
anecdotally on what some other districts
may do um by way of background the
school boards Association does conduct
superintendent searches um for our
members um it's it's a four fee service
that we provide we do anywhere between 2
and 10 in any given year myself I've
probably done two dozen in the last
maybe seven or eight years um a a medium
to a larger size School District um the
school board or say you the school board
will um usually um comprise a committee
you'll have a couple teachers a couple
administrators a couple school board
members a couple parents couple teachers
couple General community members if you
will uh that that committee will
comprise a a district leadership these
are public meetings because a
Schoolboard committee meeting your
policy committee your facilities
committee all have to be posted a notice
under under the right to no law so the
committee meetings are are public The
public's free to attend um and has a
right to attend I should say um uh they
will develop a leadership profile
develop the advertisement develop
attributes they will do community
surveys get feedback from parents get
feedback from teachers get feedback from
students feedback from the community at
large with that they develop a
leadership profile put together a um uh
uh the advertisement um number of
different ways they can advertise um
they'll do a first round of interviews
those are usually a non-public session
um which is allowable under 91 A2
paragraph 3B the hiring of any person as
a Public Employee um and then they'll
call that down to maybe two or three
finalists and then do open public
interviews with those with those final
candidates the committee usually makes a
recommendation to the school board um
and then the school board um interviews
that candidate the candidates for a
final time and ultimately makes a makes
a decision on how to hire the the
superintendent that's an ideal
circumstance some of the smaller school
districts the school board may just post
an advertisement and interview people
and people on their own um or I can also
say that if a superintendent leaves in
the middle of a school year um I go
through my what I call my roll adex I
keep a list of individuals mostly
retired superintendents or indiv
superintendents who are working
part-time that I know may be interested
and picking up another 10hour a week gig
here or there and then I'll pass them on
to the board and they'll do a a quick
interview but but so for a full search
in a medium large size District there's
opportunity for the public to to
participate thank you a followup to that
is with regards to current employment of
any of these candidates is that publicly
disclosed or
known if I may ask a clarifying question
Madam chair publicly disclosed are known
by whom the public yeah the the public
who's who would be you know because the
salary would be um paid through taxpayer
dollars and also the public being the
the people serving on the school boards
in the Committees um interviewing and
making this decision yeah thank you very
much for the question uh Madam chair um
yeah nhba generally advises that the
first interview um take place in
non-public session and the candidates um
application materials resume letters of
recommendation so on and so forth are
not publicly disclosed at that point um
because there's a privacy interest for
the individual that's is the candidate
they may not their school board if it's
a superintendent in one District their
superintendent their school board May
not know that they're looking for
another job and that can create some
some tension that you might not
necessarily want but so we tell our
school boards that when you're ready to
release the names of the quote unquote
finalists tell them on a Friday and say
look we're going to have you got 48
hours to tell your local school board or
your current employer because Monday
we're issuing a press release or Monday
I'm having an interview with the
reporter from the local newspaper and
we're going to announce that Jane Doe
current superintendent in XYZ Town new
New Hampshire is a finalist for the
superintendent in ABC town in New
Hampshire so at at some point that
information does become public Madame
chair thank you additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Mark
mle good morning and welcome to mpal and
County
government good morning put on my
glasses and pull up my notes
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee my name is Mark mlan
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire school administrators
Association our members are education
leaders throughout New Hampshire uh we
work collaboratively with the school
boards Association so much of what I was
going to say Barrett stole my thunder
which is fine I defer to his expertise
and wisdom um as you know well I should
state that the nhsa opposes this bill we
feel like it would just be curtail what
small and Rural communities can do in
their search for executive leadership
for their school districts excuse me as
you know New Hampshire is a rural State
doesn't come as a surprise cooperative
and Regional School districts are found
throughout our state and community
seeking collaboration appropriate
efficiencies economies of scale and most
importantly opportunities for their
students
will oftentimes seek to collaborate with
their administrative leadership in a way
to make sure that they are holding on to
their community's identity as well as
fostering more opportunity and savings
for their
districts that's essentially all I
wanted to state in that I think this
what this bill would do is sty me that
uh that search for
efficiency and ultimately impact the
opportunities that students are offered
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you Mr mle
questions seeing none thank
you so that's the uh the last pink card
that I
have is there anyone present who wishes
to testify on this bill who has not yet
had the opportunity to do
so okay I think the blue sheets coming
this way
so um seeing no other people to provide
testimony the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report the blue
sheets thank you madam chair on the
remote sign in we had uh 14 in support
and 11 opposed and on the today's blue
sheet we have two
opposed thank you and with that the
chair will close the public hearing on
House Bill 512 FN
spor for
we're just waiting a few minutes for the
um Prime sponsors the chair and another
committee and he's on his way
thank you for your patience
nice she is good be rela
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 562
relative to the filing of vacant
positions on elected Municipal boards
and school
boards the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor representative Alexander good
morning and welcome to Municipal and
County government thank you madam chair
and members of Municipal and County for
the record my name is Joe Alexander I
represent the town of gtown Hillsboro
District 29 um I filed this bill it's
relative to filling vacant positions on
elected mun ipal and select boards um
this bill although it's a few pages is
pretty straightforward it basically says
when the like when Municipal boards have
the right to fill a
vacancy and they choose to they choose
to fill the vacancy from people that had
ran for the position and lost if they
choose to C if they choose to fill it
with from the pool of losers they have
to pick the person who got the next
highest number of votes and that way it
respects the rule of the voter so
basically Let me Give an example um I
represent gown there was a pretty hotly
contested School Board Race um where one
person received was one person there was
a top
six you pick three the top three ended
up winning two months later there was a
resignation on the school board and the
school board chose the person that
received sixth place in that pre most
previous election instead of the person
that that received the the next highest
number of votes who also applied for the
position so I guess what I want to say
is I want this process to be fair and I
want to respect the the will of the
voters so if the if the board chooses to
fill a vacancy with an applicant that
ran in any of the last three elections
for office they must first extend the
offer to the runner up in the most
previous election this doesn't require
them this doesn't require them to pick
the run her up this just gives this says
if they are going to choose somebody
that ran in the last previous three
elections they have to first extend it
to the next highest vote getter that was
a
loser I hope that makes sense to
everybody so the first
loser okay and that mainly the intent is
just to respect the will of Voters
sometimes in races it benefits one party
over the other but it is the I feel like
in in this sense is the most Fair way to
conduct picking of replacement for a
municipal board um
so with that I'm happy to answer
questions I think this pretty
straightforward I'm sure I I could have
done better with this but I was in
another committee questions the chair
recognizes representative Guthrie for a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I really have
two if I have a runner up uh isn't it
possible that the uh in the example you
gave that the school committee could
have selected the third the Le the next
runner up they could
have isn't I if I could Madam chair uh
fall to give another exception exception
which is a possibility where you have a
uh a two person race with three
candidates
and the third candidates get six
votes because it's that's the way it is
the first the top two
candidates uh overwhelmingly and the
third candidate is someone
that just is running for because he's
interested that's or he she is
interested uh they would have to if
they'll spill passes they would have to
offer the school committee would have
have to offer the
job uh the re replacement to that runner
up even though you only got three or
four votes they would not they would not
because the language in here says if the
committee chooses to fill a vacancy with
an applicant who ran if they must choose
the first runner up they don't have to
right like we're not forcing boards to
pick the next runner up in the most
previous election that candidate might
not even want it anymore right like but
we're saying in this situation if they
do right they they that board probably
wouldn't choose the person who got six
votes but if they decided to pick
somebody in the last election cycle
they'd have to at least offer it to that
person who got six votes first in that
case the situation in gtown what
happened is there is a board who and
this happened more or less in non-public
which I think was also against the law
but um The Filling of this vacancy
happened based on almost an
ideological um
a belief that one candidate is going to
carry the board's Mission differently
than another candidate and the candidate
who got fourth place is from a
conservative wing of the town and the
candidate who got sixth place is from
more of a left wing of the town and so
this situation the school board picked
the more left-wing candidate to help
fill the
vacancy so again I think I'm not trying
to bring party into this at all because
this has nothing to do with partisan
politics what this has to do is it
respecting the will of the voter so the
next highest vote getter should be the
one that the positions offered to if
they choose to do it but they don't have
to representative Colby has a question
thank you madam chair um I'm looking for
clarification I'm not sure that the
language of the
bill is the same as this what you're
describing I guess in how I read this
and please please correct me if a board
receives
applications then they would have to
review the last three prior elections to
determine if any of the applicants have
run for office run for that particular
position correct then the bill would
suggests they pass up all other
candidates even if an application came
in that were more
qualified to offer offer the position to
the first runner up from the previous
election am I am I no what would happen
is say there's or they just have to
notify say there's three no say there's
um three people are looking to fill a
position on a library Board of
Trustees one of them ran in the last
previous election the other two have
never run for the position at all the
board could pick one of the other two
that have never run for the position at
all but say at the library Board of
Trustees two of the candidates both ran
for
trustee and they wanted to offer the
position to one of those candidates they
would have to offer it to the person who
got the most amount of votes in the last
previous election but they do not have
to
followup yes that is not
what the language describes so that's
why explain explain me where the
language is is vague to you I'm just
trying ask really the committee um and
thank you madam chair I'm sorry if the
committee Cho es to fill a vacancy with
an applicant who ran in any of the last
three elections for the office they must
first extend an offer to the runner up
in the most recent prior
election
I the way I see it is that that's pretty
straightforward and this is this is um
the reason why this bill is so long is
it has to do with budget committee
membership Charter commission membership
Cemetery truste V vacancies um District
officer vacancies Town election
vacancies so like Library boards and
supervisor of the checklist that's why
it's so long is they have they had to
change the RSA in every single place
where a municipal board or School Board
is being appointed but it it says the
same thing in every paragraph just to
make it clear across all the rsas okay
thank you further questions
representative
Dolan thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question of
course we all know that in local
elections they were talking about here
Dynamics change once an election is
complete candidates selected or voted in
or voted out U so my question is given
that isn't the right thing just to hold
a special election and and let the
voters decide based on the remaining
candidates that are available to them
that are signed up you know have a an
open and honest election through a
special election I know there's some
cost involved but yeah that's a that's a
great question and and this bill is in
the committee hands I was just trying to
find a way to make it as inexpensive for
a town to fill a vacancy while Al also
respecting the will of the voters in the
last previous election
so the the town towns already have a
right to appoint somebody to fill these
vacancies all it's extending is the the
next highest vote getter would have an
opportunity if they choose to fill it um
but I don't think that we necessarily
need a whole special election for it I
think it is an added cost for the town
and you might not have the same amount
of turnout for that position so um the
the bill is in your hands but I think
that this is the most inexpensive way to
also um respect the will of Voters
without having an extra
election the chair will recognize
representative stavis and then
representative Walker thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um what
if what if the runner up in the most
recent prior election has moved
away then they don't have to offer that
position because they wouldn't be
qualified for the position it doesn't
say that sorry madam chair no and and
respectfully they can't offer the
position to somebody who's not qualified
to serve I I don't think you need the
language in the RSA to say they have to
offer it even if they don't even live in
the municipality or the Zone because
they would be
unqualified thank you you're
welcome chair recognizes representative
Walker is this language is uh kind of
contradictory in my view you say here
that if the board chooses to fill a
vacancy with an applicant who ran in
last three elections you must first
offer it to the runner
up and then you say at the end of your
sentence but they don't have
to that kind of contradicts
itself okay first sentence if the
committee
chooses
okay that that right there is them
allowing the choice to pick between
applicants that have ran before and
those that have not if they choose not
to to choose any of the applicants who
ran then it would this this wouldn't
even apply because nobody ran for that
position if they do they must first
extend it doesn't mean they have to may
I follow up
yes how can a board choose not to fill a
vacancy if it's on an important
board maybe it's a town I'm from the
city of Rochester that doesn't make
sense to me because if they choose to
fill it they can leave it vacant but if
you choose to fill it you must take the
next guy the guy may not be qualified
for it representative I think you're
reading it wrong because if the
committee chooses to fill the
vacancy with an
applicant they must first extend it to
the the runner up that they could choose
not to fill it they could choose to fill
they could choose to fill it with Mickey
Mouse right but if Mickey Mouse if
Donald Duck ran in the last election and
Donald Duck was applying and they choose
to go between Donald Chuck Donald Duck
Minnie Mouse and then Mickey Mouse
didn't even run they'd have to choose
Donald Duck because he got the next
amount of votes it's it's I I'm trying I
don't I don't know how else to explain
this maybe
it's representative Walker could you
shut your mic off oh I know so I might
be able to help here thank you so um the
construct of the sentence might be a
little off I would like to see if then
so the if Clause needs to be taken in it
in its entirety and it would be if the
committee chooses to fill a vacancy with
an applicant who
ran in any of the last three elections
so all those things need to be true if
that's the way that they're going to do
with all parts being true
then then the the bill language says is
that they must first extend the offer to
the runner up with the most well it
would be the person with the most um
votes in the most recent prior election
so you have to take it all together and
then I would also say that perhaps what
you're trying to do here is make this be
enabling by by it's a choice it's not
you have to do it this way it's you may
do it this way if this is the path
you're going down I don't know if that
helps further questions that's like that
and and thank you I wasn't an English
major and I think the if then Clause
really helps clarify that so thank you
very much Madam chair yeah and there's
no then in the sentence either
so okay um
representative um
Gerard thank you madam chair thank you
repres for taking my question again I
appreciate what you have in the spill
and from what I'm hearing you say
basically this may actually have the
boards were they're sitting here trying
to get candidates that haven't run for
election so that way if there was
somebody they didn't want to have on it
they could actually get around it that
way is basic if I'm hearing what you're
saying correctly yep thank
you further questions representative
majority is recognized thank you madam
chair wooden thank you for taking my
question um what if there was a
tie for the runner up and you know one
more is that kind contemplated here it's
not okay it's a great
question I think that would be very yeah
I don't
representative
um grund grund is recognized and then
repres I know you've had a couple ties
representative and then representative
Guthrie be because you already asked a
question so representative grund thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question so this is just selecting to
fill the open vacancy and then the
following thing that happens is that
there's an election because someone has
to actually run for the remaining part
of that
position be a so you're not asking to
override that piece you're just asking
for that it could be a three-month piece
it could be a six Monon stint until they
10 days yep okay it could be as yeah
that's great a good point representative
goth
three thank you madam chair for letting
me ask an additional question thank you
for your question
uh I it it I have a problem with whether
or not this is is necessary because this
the school committee or The Bard
selectman or whoever's making the
appointment can follow this this
direction if they they want but are you
assuming that the person who comes in
third in a twers race is in fact the the
third choice of the electorate or is it
just that they happen to get be in the
race for a two person person race and
they come in third I don't know if
that's clear or not no I mean I mean
hypothetically if there's more
undervotes than that person received
maybe they aren't the third choice but
nobody else stepped ahead maybe if
there's a right in that received more
votes than the person on the ballot for
third place they would offer it to the
right end because that person received
more votes
so I I think it's hypothetical I mean I
don't I don't know how else to answer
that question representative if I follow
up mam chair just if I could uh just
quickly it's it it seems to me that what
you're trying to do is a good thing
because uh I've I've had been in this
position a lot of times and we try have
always tried to pick that person who
showed an interest particularly if there
was nobody else interest CU it's all all
kinds of possibilities but I would
suggest to you that uh without this bill
the individual committees who are making
the reappointment or the fill in
appointment have the right to do this
and should be aware that there's good
process to follow what you're trying to
do that it it may be best practice
representative I think in the ideal
world if a if a committee make an
appointment they would first offer I
think think they would first offer it to
the next highest vot getter I think if
you know I serve on the budget committee
if that was something that happened I
would be like okay well who got the next
amount like who's interested but I think
the problem that we run into is maybe
not in your District but in other
districts there
are um ideological boards right that
have a clear position on something and
they want to move in a certain direction
and the next highest vot atter might not
be the one that helps them fulfill the
mission that they're trying to do
but the six Place person does so what
I'm trying to do the intent of this bill
is to is to respect the voters in my
situation of gtown that you know the
person lost by 40 votes but the person
they picked was somebody that lost by
hundreds so it it just seems like
respecting what the voters did on town
meeting day I they were a loser both of
them were losers right but one was less
of a loser right and I think in that
situation they should if you're going to
offer it you're going to offer it to the
next
person thank you thank you madam
chair additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Brody
Des good morning Mr Dees welcome to
Municipal and County government uh good
morning thank you madam chairwoman thank
you to the committee uh for the record
my name is biry Dees I represent the N
Municipal Association
and we are opposed to the bill as
written um our interpretation is the
same as what representative Colby shared
which is um specifically we we interpret
extend the offer as offering the
position to the individual and we read
it as provided that the board chooses to
fill a vacancy so if they choose to fill
a vacancy on the Committees and the
boards listed in this legislation um if
they offer that vacancy to anyone who
ran in the last three elections um they
must first extend the offer to the
runner up of the most prior election um
now it's been pointed out that someone
could be a runner up but lose by a lot
and that happens often in many local
elections um there are people who might
be interested or unqualified for a board
and um and the voters reject them and so
that's the will of the voters so to then
make it so it's automatically that they
become the first person who has to be
offered the vacancy um is kind of
undermining the will of the voters in it
also impedes the ability of local boards
and committees to determine who is the
most qualified candidate to serve on the
board um I also want to point out that
the that a person who ran in the
previous three elections may have W or
been an experience incumbent it's very
often that boards will go to someone to
fill a vacancy and to serve out the rest
of a term who has experience and has won
elections because they might not be
interested in running again so it kind
of guarantees that the seat will open up
again but in the interim you have a very
experienced person who will be on the
board and serve and help further um good
efficient government for that Community
um again as pointed out by
representative Guthrie this kind of
impedes local boards and committies
ability to choose the most qualified
Andor experienced person and Boards do
try to find you know they try to choose
candidates who have shown interest in
serving the office but there are times
where someone has shown interest but
they're just not qualified and the
voters have resly rejected them in
multiple elections I would imagine a
border or committee is not going to want
to appoint someone who the voters have
rejected multiple times I mean you know
the voters would probably be very
confused and upset um if that was the
case um and these are also local issues
and are best addressed locally and this
kind of over complicates a simple
process boards and committees currently
post say there's a vacancy there's an
opening we're looking for applicants
people will write letters in the boards
will review those letters and they will
choose the person who is the most
qualified and they do take into context
have they ran an election have they won
an election have they served on a Bo
board what's your experience
professional experience often times can
be something they want to really
consider in a candidate um so for all
those reasons we'd ask you to please
reject the bill as written and um I'll
answer any questions if there are any
thank you thank you
questions representative grund thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question and something that was asked
earlier um I just want to get an
opinion if you're truly on the will of
the voters would you hold a special
election
instead
I I don't know if there's currently in
statute the ability to hold a special
election for some of these municipal
offices should they become vacant but
the special election would happen like
there would be a special election but it
would happen because it would happen at
the next town meeting um so when the
election of officers happens so um let's
say it's a select board and um someone
resigns with a year left on their term
there would be a special election um
that you know would happen at the next
town meeting to fill out the rest of the
term for the last year of it
um however there are times where
especially where you have a board of
Selectmen where it's three people um you
you don't want um you don't want only
two people on that board right because
then it requires you know you have one
person get sick or injured or couldn't
make a meeting now you're not able to
make a quorum and your board of
Selectmen essentially would not be able
to find function so um there's a benefit
to filling these vacancies before the
special election but no matter what a
special election is going to happen um
you know whether or not you fill the
vacancy so I hope that answers your
question further
questions okay
um with regards to special elections do
you know for sure if Municipal
municipalities have special elections
not in the sense like the legislature
does where one of the towns will say you
know there's an opening on this you know
for our legislative seat and we're
requesting a special election and then
you have a special election that's set
you know on a very it could be you know
that's set by the Secretary of State but
there is a special election that
happens after um like for example I I
filled the vacancy of a library Board of
Trustees seat um previously taking this
role and there was a special election to
fill out the last year of that term
so it's typically you fill the vacancy
or you leave it open and then at the
next town meeting you elect someone to
fill out the rest of the vacancy um yeah
I just I'm hesitating because using the
term special election is a little
confusing I agree yeah okay so I did
have a question with regards to budget
committee memberships so um in your
opinion and I'm just zoning in on budget
committee because I was a member of a
Cooperative School District budg budget
committee do you feel that this language
um is sufficient for the case where like
I said a budget committee is cooperative
and the committee membership is
comprised of more than one town is is is
this language sufficient to to address
that type of a case um in my reading the
statute cited is not the statute for um
Cooperative School District budget
committees so that would
be an Omission in the bill
it it's just not
included thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so that was the last pink card that
I
have so I will ask is there anyone
present who wishes to speak on the bill
who has not yet had the opportunity to
do so seeing none the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets thank thank you madam shair
uh on the remote sign in there were four
in support and 140 as
opposed on the paper sheet we have one
opposed thank you and with that the
public hearing on House Bill 562 is now
closed
e e
so we are a little bit behind
schedule yes we are um at this time the
chair will open the public hearing on a
proposed non- gerine amendment number
2025 -
0153 to House Bill 125 enabling
municipalities to tax standing wood and
Timber on land used for carbon
sequestration this amendment prohibits
the placement of land owned by the
county or state and land in trusts that
receive Public Funding from being
enrolled in carbon sequestration
programs the hearing is now
open good morning thank you Madam chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is representative Arnold Davis I
represent Coos District 2 I'm from Maron
New Hampshire thank you for hearing my
testimony here today I am here to
introduce this non gerain amendment to
House Bill
123 this bill is this amendment is
actually very simple it prohibits County
and state lands in any lands that
receive Public
Funding from being entered into the cin
sequestration
program these properties were purchased
with tax dollars and intended for
traditional uses putting these lands
into Carin projects could disqualify
them from some of these uses in which
they were intended
for we may hear testimony today claiming
that the state does not want to give up
potential possible Revenue in the future
they they have not entered into cin
projects before they're not doing any
now so if this is something that
potentially could be done in the future
I believe it would be prudent to revisit
this at that time for now I believe we
should bring stability to the timber
industry and to the wood products
industry of New
Hampshire uh there's there's something
called
additionality so if the premise behind
this whole cin sequestration program is
to save trees and lessen greenhouse gas
emissions to slow down global warming
then counting trees that are not going
to be cut anyways disqualifies them from
cbin projects one example would be if
there's a conservation easement that
does not allow you to cut the trees
anyways this this type of property would
not
qualify so th this is different than
private land owners have rights we're
not trying to infringe upon that but
public lands paid for with tax dollars
should be viewed differently the public
Forest should be managed at a high
standard best forestry practices not
just for the woods Product Industry but
also for economic development for
wildlife habitat for the prevention of
forest fires and and for the the health
of the forest itself plus
Recreation um before I before I open up
for questions I I just have like kind of
an FYI this is the second carbon bill
you you guys have heard in a week uh
does this whole premise is about about
sequestering carbon out of the
atmosphere does anybody here know what
the percentage of carbon that's in the
atmosphere
today would would you believe me if I
said it's less than half a
percent okay so that's that's what the
big fear is here now it's a low number
but it's significant I'm not trying to
trying to make light of it if uh 12,000
years ago we were where we're standing
today was under ice that that number was
lower so moving that number just a
little bit does
matter so this whole carbon uh premise
is this state is 84% forested we do a
very good job of managing it for a lot
of different
reasons I I just don't like the idea
that California the compliance
Market will will continue to pollute at
the same rate by purchasing credits that
are actually making us manage our forest
in a a new way that I I don't believe is
beneficial to the state and so with that
I'd open up for questions other
questions for the prime
sponsor seeing none thank you oh oh
sorry no representative majorities it
might be more thank you madam chairwoman
it might be more of a question for for
you I'm just trying to understand
process uh this seems like it's a
Germain amendment to what we're doing so
I'm not that it really might matter I'm
just trying to understand completely
what we are
doing thank you for the question
representative so um with regards to um
issues like this amendments like this
it's at the determination of the speaker
and the speaker as well as I believe
that the house clerk reviewed the link
and um determine that it was non gerain
I will allow the prime speaker to
supplement that explanation no that's
your your spot on um the subject matter
is similar but it affects different
rsas
uh so that's I believe that was the
reason for the non- gerain
amendment yep F further questions
seeing none thank you yeah thank
you at this time the chair recognizes
representative
ulette good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government good morning Madam chair and
good morning committee members I'll be
very brief U just to expand a little bit
on what representative Davis has said I
look at it and I think about it we look
at franconian Notch Canon Mountain Area
I mean that's really a a jewel of New
Hampshire the um Department of forest
and lands have done a great job managing
that that area keeping it wild keeping
open hikers skiers and uh we'll continue
to do so so in the carbon SE Quest
Station Market if you have a piece of
Timberland that has no intention of ever
being
cut it doesn't qualify for carbon
sequesteration and that's a lot of our
our state
lands the other part uh second thing I
just want to bring out is land that is
managed for carbon sequest station a lot
of times it really
changes how we look at the land how the
land's used because not necessarily a
growing uh timber for
carbon is compatible with animal habitat
and
Recreation um if you do it on your
private land that's private land and you
know we all uh believe that um you
should have the freedom to do what you
like with your property but when it
comes to state land or County Land
that's uh bought with public monies um
the
traditional uh uses of land when the
money was spent and bought for that
property should stay
intact um that concludes my my uh my
statement and I'm open to any questions
are there any
questions I have a question um so you I
heard you say that the carbon
sequestration program affects how the
the
forests they they are managed but you
also I heard you say this carbon
sequestration program also affects how
these um forests are used so could you
you just expound upon the what the
impact would be for state-owned forests
and how they would uh how that would
impact the use of the forests for for
like the public oh sure absolutely thank
you um a lot of the traditional uses in
our forest of course is
hunting and when we're growing carbon
for sequest station our main goal is to
grow as much wood as fast as we can so
different species grow at different
rates different species of animals have
habitat in different species of wood and
they're not always the same fast growing
species is the best habitat or
compatible habitat for our our animals
so if you are growing a certain species
of wood to get as much carbon as you can
you might have a very
um uh a very
desert likee um habitat for the animals
there won't be animals there because
they don't produce the feed that they
need so that's that's one way where you
know growing isn't compatible with um
with traditional
uses representative
stavis thank you madam chair can you
please explain to
me what it is about about using a forest
for carbon
sequestration that in fact prevents it
from being used for recreation and other
uses again thank you for your question
it's kind of twofold again uh looking at
some of the um traditional uses like I
just explained with hunting and and
losing some of the habitat but the
second part of it is
um in
most uh situations a lot of situations
we've seen around the country the use of
motorized Motorsports in uh carbon
sequest station is almost a conflict of
philosophies you know they're growing
the carbon to keep help the environment
but at the same time they don't want uh
gas powered engines in that area so it's
uh it can be a conflict as far as uh
motorized Motor
Sports
yes thank you for answering answer my
question just a brief followup so in
fact there's really nothing about using
a forest for carbon
sequestration that conflicts with using
a forest for recreational purposes
unless you restrict some kind of
recreational purpose I guess I'm trying
to get at you know what what is it
really that's different about a forest
of standing
trees that's used for carbon
sequesteration and any other Forest
thank you again for your question um
again on the motorized side it's kind of
a philos philosophical thing but on the
animal habitat thing it's not um as a
general rule the best uh animal habitat
for our deer and some of our smaller
game is in the young Forest because
there's plenty of feed when you have an
a a a mature Forest that's not being cut
because of growing carbon you have large
canopies and there's no light getting to
the ground underneath and there's no
feed for the animals so a traditional
use in New Hampshire which I mean
there's hundreds of thousands of hunters
that um it's possible that that land
would not
be um conductive for
hunters representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um so when a
contract is made by a town to purchase a
piece of
land does the contract typically stay
what the continued use of the land would
be or does it just State purchase price
and ident identify the trative land um
or does a contract not say anything the
town decides the best use of the land
well thank you for your question and
this non- derain bill uh excludes Town
business so this bill have no effect
over any municipalities
only deals with counties and
state do you have followup yeah so I
guess let me clarify so when the town
has land right they for this carbon
sequestration that we're talking about
it might be a town
might when the contract was made to
purchase that land right from the town
like the town purchased it from a person
or whatever was the contract stay what
the continue do the land would be so the
town then needs to follow that or do
they get to decide the best could I um
interject so just to help and to be
clear okay count is that that the
non-main amendment does not pertain to
municip municipalities it's only limited
to counties or state
forests so it's does that help form your
question thank you yeah I I was thinking
of the original purchase thank
you representative Colby
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I'm skipping over the
county and state and moving into I think
what's the sleeper here is the land in
trusts
how does this effectively instruct
private land owners what to do with
their
property in my opinion absolutely not
this is has to do with just public
lands additional
questions representative
Murphy are there any public lands that
have been gifted and any of those gifts
have restrictions on
them I yes we're there has been lands
that have been
gifted um to the state um and as far as
restrictions I don't know as far as
carbon not that I
believe so like land was you know for
for hunting or representative Murphy do
you have a
followup yeah do
you we just trying to keep
order representative
Davis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking yet another question
um can you foresee some point in the
future when forest's Forest use for
carbon sequestration could coexist
nicely with Forest used for
recreation and produce a significant
amount of revenue for the state that
would benefit taxpayers and and does
this legislation Forstall that Evolution
taking place
is it possible it could be possible um
but again
the land that was either bought by the
state or given to the state
um I look at it is was um done for
traditional uses or had some
restrictions on whatever there was but I
think that if the state wanted to uh
have a piece to property and
um wanted to put it in something that
wasn't traditional or part of the
purchase or or gift then they have the
option to come back to this um this body
and and uh have it
approved additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very much next the chair recognizes
Mr Jason stock
good morning and welcome to Municipal
and County
government good morning for the record
I'm Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association and
uh the second time in two weeks we've
come together to talk carbon
um I appreciate the opportunity to
testify we we oppose this we oppose this
amendment and let me explain why um last
week we had there was a lot of
discussion about uh taxes Timber taxes
and I provided a copy of our our
organization's kind of policy statement
kind of the filter that we use when we
evaluate policy proposals relative to to
Forest carbon
um representative Colby hit the nail on
the head lines 12 and 13 this shall
include any land put into trust which
receives any public money from the
state when we read that um I immediately
called our our attorney and said what
does this mean and he said it's a great
question people in families put land in
trust all the
time revocable irre revocable trust you
do it as part of your estate plan you
have children you want to pass that land
down to your children or you have a
spouse you know you it's it's all part
of your personal estate planning you'll
put your assets into
trust um and so that's when we look at
this language there's kind of two fil or
two two check offs there one is it in
trust sure I put it into trust so my
children I can I can do it as part of my
estate planning the second piece is any
public money from the state any public
money so let's say I get a grant from
the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department to do some wildlife habitat
management out there I'm going to mow
some Fields I'm going to create some
whipper will whipper will habitat for
for you know a bird that's uh not as
abundant as it should be or I'm going to
get a grant from the New Hampshire
Department of Agriculture to to control
some invasive plant species or an
invasive bug to help me defay my cost
that checks box to and so in that in
this instance when we look at this bill
both boxes are checked and that would
prohibit me or my family that land
that's in my family trust from enrolling
in a forest carbon
program um and so in our in our position
statement we were very
clear the a landowner's ability and this
is a property rights issue for us here
you have a land owner that wants to
enter into a private contract with
someone that wants to buy an asset on
their property in this case carbon the
value of those trees is is standing
carbon
um this this as proposed in those
instances where it's in a trust and I
may have received any money
it could be a grant or the state could
have purchased a piece of aof way across
my property or Department of
Transportation gave me money to pile
snow or something who knows I would be
prohibited from exercising that property
right to enter into a private contract
with an entity that wants to purchase my
carbon so for that reason we we we
oppose this bill um on the issue of
public land they can coexist with with
Recreation they certainly can coexist
and as I testified last week they can
coexist with with uh forest forest
management albeit the forest management
would
change um we do support we do support
the sponsor's intent on that piece and
again as I testified last week we have
members on this issue that are land
owners we have members that are also
loggers Foresters and
Sawmills and when we when we evaluated
this issue we said look where do we draw
the line we recognize property rights
that's clear on public land particularly
state land um it it's our belief that
there were traditional uses when that
property was acquired with public money
there were traditional uses carbon was
not contemplated if it is the desire of
the the general court to to start
entering you know allowing State Forest
to enter into carbon contracts then then
cify that in in law but that land was a
purchased with with money that was
public money with an expectation that
that land would be managed for multiple
traditional uses that include Recreation
and of course Forest Products um the the
state lands the the division of forest
and lands does a great job managing our
forest and
that their Timber sales and their
forestry are an important source of are
an important source of raw ingredient
raw material for our Mills across the
state and what we would like to avoid is
a situation where someone says aha I've
got a clever way to plug a budget hole
let's take all this state land and and
roll it into a carbon program and here
we go problem solved and so for that
reason we thought
we we took the position that certainly
in the case of State lands that it was
not appropriate um at this point to just
say all right um you know enroll those
in or allow those to be enrolled in a
carbon program again you're the you're
the Arbiter on all of this you're the
general court and you can decide at a
later date yeah we want go for it let's
do some let's do some carbon and let's
try to to do that but at this point
we're of the opinion keep state land and
using the traditional uses continue to
manage it as we have but um and so with
that I'll I'll include I'll conclude my
testimony I'm I'm happy to try and
answer any questions and I appreciate
your patience with this tricky
subject thank you questions represented
Davis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question do do you
think that this is an not a single issue
but a whole group of issues that
requires a tremendous amount of study
from both policy environmental Financial
stakeholders I do and and last week you
got a glimpse into the timber tax kind
of the municipal tax piece of it this
week you're getting another glimpse into
kind of public land management and in
kind of the kind of bigger picture of
Land Management you've heard in
testimony about kind of the
additionality and some of the bigger
picture issues about just carbon trading
in general California markets private
there are private markets out there
there are entities out there such as
Microsoft that will because of some of
their environmental policies and goals
will enter into what are called
voluntary markets this is a big issue
it's a new issue um and again as I
offered last week representative stavis
chairman power I we're willing to work
with the committee if you do wish to to
do a study and take a bigger picture
look at this um and we certainly want to
work with with the sponsors of the bill
and make sure
that we can come to some resolution but
this is a big big
issue thank you further questions
represent representative Jory thank you
madam chairwoman and this is a a
fascinating topic one that we don't
typically hear in Municipal and County
so it's it's fascinating just to try to
understand it which is the nature of my
question so I think of the southeast
Land Trust uh now which which which has
Forest which were purchase through
grants do I understand correctly that
that to the best of your knowledge they
could not enter into that voluntary
Market to sell carbon credits
currently they can they can yeah and in
and in fact last week there was there is
a registry at the in the state of New
Hampshire of you know so if you enter
into a carbon program you that land gets
that land gets enrolled in a registry at
the division of forest and lands and
there are there are some land there I
believe there are two land trust
currently in that registry right now I
think it's bear with me I think it's
let me just take a
peek Lakes Region conservation trust um
is is one of them so there there are
there are land trusts that can can
enroll in it um Can enroll case of selt
um
madok um nonprofits can now again coming
back to the bill if that land were in
some some way shap perform in a
trust however you define what is a trust
if that parcel is in a trust and there
was public any public money part of
either the transaction or part of the
stewardship work that's occurring on the
property if this non- gerain amendment
were to pass that would be bumped out of
Eligibility thank you're welcome
representative stavis
thank you madam chair and thank you
taking another question uh is it your
understanding that the um New Hampshire
old growth forest Network would be
eligible to enroll in a carbon
sequestration
program I'm not familiar
with with that um if it's an
organization or if it's a land owner I
I'm not I I can't speak to that um what
I do know is the way many of these
carbon contracts do work is there is a
purchase of standing carbon so an
inventory is
done the existing carbon that's on the
property is valued and and purchased and
then there's subsequent growth that will
get that will get sold at future dates
depending on tree
growth and so I don't know if the The
Entity that you're mentioning is in fact
a land trust but if they do have if
they're a private entity that owns Real
Estate Old growth or otherwise and
that's why I'm raising this there is
there are opportunities to participate
in carbon
markets further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair calls Ms Meredith
Hatfield
good morning and welcome to Municipal
and County government thank you madam
chair members of the committee Meredith
Hatfield for The Nature Conservancy um
you heard from us last week uh on the
underlying Bill uh where we raised
concerns and we also have concerns with
this proposed amendment um many of which
uh have already been raised so I won't
repeat them um but we do believe that um
participating in a forest carbon Market
can coexist exist with a lot of
traditional uses and we've actually seen
uh the folks at the state level who are
charged with uh protecting and managing
our state lands do a really good job of
making sure that they have the ability
to do what they need to do on our state
lands so we would urge you to not um
hamstring counties or uh state agencies
from having options for a variety of
ways of managing lands we we think it
actually wouldn't be wor able to come
back to the legislature if there was an
opportunity to do so and to have to seek
specific legislation in that instance um
and we also as I said last week we do
think this is a very complicated issue
and that it probably would benefit from
uh further study and
investigation um and lastly um I'll say
again you know we we are very
sympathetic to uh the concerns in the
North Country around um the Connecticut
Lakes Headwaters which um seems to have
uh inspired a lot of this legislation
and the future of the forest products
industry so we think that also merits
attention um from all of us in this Nate
uh not just folks in the North Country
thank you thank you are there
questions seeing none thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Robert
Johnson
good morning and welcome to Municipal
and County government good morning Madam
chair members of the committee for the
record Rob Johnson representing the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau as the
federation's policy director and Farm
Bureau is an
organization of of the 10 County Farm
Bureau organizations and our membership
is made up of uh family farms uh
supporters and Affiliated businesses
just under 2500 in total and uh our our
Members Own and manage hundreds of
thousands of Acres throughout the state
we took no position on the underlying
Bill and nor do we have one but we are
opposed to to this amendment and uh it's
it's already been mentioned but that
that sentence in lines uh 12 and 13
shall not include any land put into
trust which receives any public money
from the
state any public money from the state um
there's there's farm and Forest land all
over the state that is under an
easement that may or may not be but uh
may be uh under in a
trust and anybody who understands
conservation easements they often
requires money being cobbled together
from all kinds of sources including
State the way this reads as well it says
and I'm going to it says that um which
receives any public money from the state
well what about Federal money that goes
to the state and then dispersed that way
is that is that included it's a question
we don't
know I
think I think what in in listening to
representative
ducet in answering the questions it
appears to me that he's reading that
last sentence to say this should include
any land put into public trust is my
guess but that's not what this
says we strongly believe that that land
owners uh private land
owners
um they well the that option is valuable
to to to to to enter the carbon Market
we want to preserve
that I guess in closing i' just like to
point out another example is just think
about it a I'm a I'm a a private land
owner I've I've uh put my my property
into a trust for various reasons and I
don't think I have to explain those and
I have uh been approached by uh an
entity that would like to put a trail a
public use Trail through my property and
I say sure in their in their state funds
are go to that that now prohibits me
from participating in a in a carbon
Market that's just not right
Z thank you for your attention I'll
leave it at that thank you other
questions seeing none thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Brody
Dees welcome back thank you appreciate
it thank you madam chairwoman and thank
you to the committee for the record my
name is Brody Dees I represent the
Hampshire Municipal Association and um
we are in support of this amendment
representative Davis's other amend to
have a yield tax on carbon tonnage and
the underlying bill
um I won't rehash some of the things
that have been discussed with some of
the concerns with the amendment um from
some other stakeholders we're going to
have a meeting later today to kind of
you know discuss more in depth how
exactly we want to deal with this issue
but um the the issue is is that the
state may gain revenues from entering
into these types of lease agreements um
to allow carbon sequestration but it
does
um at the municipalities detriment in
their local taxpayers and the local
Timber industry by not by not
incentivizing the reasonable cutting of
Timber um there is no collection of the
yield tax by the municipalities and some
municipalities such as Pittsburgh each
year 5 to 10% of their budget is funded
with Timber tax um the reason for this
kind of this um carbon sequestration
industry existing is because the tax
schemes in other states and countries
that are kind of creating this new
artificial industry and ultimately it'll
hurt municipalities unless
municipalities are able to tax the
carbon tonnage and be able to recoup
those loss revenues from the timber tax
and also there's a trickle down effect
where the timber industry um
disproportionately in the North Country
Carol County or Grafton County um where
they're going to lose um they're going
to lose their own business uh revenues
um once you start cutting Timber as stop
cutting Timber as much um there's just
less productivity in the entire industry
that depends on the uh Timber cutting um
as was previously stated by our
organization and I'll restate it again
RSA 79 colon 5 which currently is you
know the existing statute that tries to
deal with the loss of Timber revenues is
um unworkable and we wouldn't recommend
that municipalities utilize that statute
to try to um to try to gain um tax
revenue via credits for uncut Timber um
standing Timber it's too ambiguous the
way it's written is based on general tax
based on um previous laws so it wouldn't
solve the issue um solving the issue is
taxing the carbon tonnage as a yield tax
under the existing Timber tax RSA 79 and
I'm helping municipalities um be able to
preserve this Revenue source that helps
their property taxpayers thank you are
there questions with regards to the non-
gerine
amendment seeing none thank you thank
you
next the chair recognizes Mr Bill
ardinger good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government good morning Madame
chairperson and members of the committee
it's um good to be here my name is Bill
aringer I'm an attorney at wrath young
and Pignatelli with in the conquered
office our client is Aurora sustainable
lands Aurora is the entity that is the
current private owner of the connetic
Connecticut Lake Headwater Forest
146,000 Acres a very important land for
the State of New Hampshire for the North
country and for all of those in uh who
use that precious property we I am here
today to testify in
opposition to this non Germain Amendment
the reasons have been stated uh
representative Colby was dead-on correct
with the question what does that second
sentence mean if this bill only applies
to land that is owned directly or
indirectly by the state or a County
government my client has no immediate
concern concern with that however if you
look at the lack of clarity in that
second sentence one of the most poorly
drafted unclear sentences which involves
very significant Stakes we don't know
what the word this means we don't know
it may be as the sponsors and
representatives indicated oh no this
refers to the first sentence which means
only state own land if that's the case
again Aurora need not be directly
involved in this particular issue um
include land put in a trust what kind of
trust in fact Aurora owns the
Connecticut Lakes Headwater Forest
through a special form of trust which
got us here to the table to bring
testimony to your committee on this
non-german amendment um receiving public
money from the state uh Mr stock and and
others who testified pointed this out
it's unclear what that means I grew up
in Cornish New Hampshire on a farm uh my
parents who passed away owned the farm
in trust they had the uh much of the
forest land enrolled in current use it's
and they received grants my parents did
and I helped them with it uh on various
cases for agricultural grants and others
does this a
apply to that Family Farm now I'm
speaking for myself here not Aurora but
it would be many many many other private
owners as has been testified to one
thing that hasn't been testified to is
if the legislature were to
try to write this correctly to apply
apply to private owned property that
where private owners have the right to
decide to hire Harvest Timber they have
the right to let people on for tourism
uses they have many ways of earning
income uh it Aurora does but so do
private land owners and one of those may
be this developing carbon sequestration
system out there another way to get
income from your private ownership of
private property the constitution of
this state and the Federal Constitution
prohibits governments from taking
private property either directly through
eminent domain or in many cases in one I
think this language would point to where
it's kind of targeted to a particular
format it would prohibit a regulatory
taking in other words taking away the
right of a private owner to benefit from
their private property uh I think that
if this language were interpreted to
apply to private property you would have
another issue that other people who
testified haven't brought forward but
that it would violate the federal and
state constitution New Hampshire has one
of the strongest protections for private
property rights in the country and we
just had an amendment a number of years
back uh that strengthened that even more
i' finally close with and be happy to
take questions that Aurora my client
uh continues to manage its property this
very precious property consistent with
the terms and the spirit of the
conservation easement with the state of
New Hampshire we work with the state of
New Hampshire regular regularly we uh
and trying to get the stewardship plan
finished we're working on that we work
with stakeholders we are very happy to
have Timber harvesting continue on the
property even though it's been enrolled
in a carbon program since
2013 and it's been the fact that it's
been enrolled has been in the existing
state stewardship plan uh there's been
harvesting going on regularly uh of
Timber since that time period subject to
important things like weather and
markets weather has been very tough up
there recently with entire Road systems
washed out and with warmer you know this
winter we've got a frozen pack in in our
in my family's property when you had
Frozen land that was the time to do the
harvesting we've got frozen land but our
roads have been washed out up there so I
think there's a lot of reasons to go in
but we are continuing to harvest up
there consistent with the terms of the
easement we are also very supportive of
Tourism efforts of motorized vehicles uh
of hunting and of preserving the
incredible quality of that forest for
wildlife for um the environment and and
uh and we intend to continue to do so
and the fact that we're here is just to
let you know how much a partner we
intend to be with the state of New
Hampshire and we but we expect that the
state will continue to work with us as a
private owner consistent with private
property rights and I'd be happy to
answer any questions thank you thank you
attorney ardinger are there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you the last pink card that I have here
is from Mr Matt
Ley good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning thank you uh for the record I'm
Matt Ley I'm the public policy director
for the Society of protection of New
Hampshire Forest uh we also oppose this
amendment and we do that
knowing as you've heard from some of the
previous speakers the concerns about
these Forest carbon markets uh
specifically the loss of uh tax revenue
to
municipalities um so we understand that
but you know the force Society also
views these um Forest carbon projects as
just a another tool that a forest land
owner could use to help them better
manage their forc resources so it's um
again it's it's a tool um um so you know
our concern with the amendment is to
have you know first a blanket
prohibition as it would apply to um
State and County Properties but probably
more of concerning to us and we are a
private non-profit land trust that one
sentence that's been discussed I mean we
certainly view that um as impacting
private Forest land owners that's a
concern um so again you know the issue
of force carbon Force management
is very complex you could literally talk
for days and weeks about this subject
um and so I you know again I you know
what's being proposed we just think is
um sort of
overreach about the current level of
forest land that's actually enrolled in
New Hampshire in these Forest uh markets
the um State of New Hampshire division
of forest lands does have a carbon
registry and I think there's seven or
eight properties that are enrolled
totally about 180,000 Acres 140,000 of
those acres is one project so I just
think as we're trying to figure out a
way to be fair to municipalities who may
be losing revenue from these deals that
we don't go too far in the other
direction and actually end up
prohibiting um the you know um decisions
that a a forest ler may want to take to
help them manage their Forest recess so
again we oppose the amendment but I'm
happy to answer any
questions thank you are
questions seeing none thank you great
thank you so that is the final pink card
that I have is there anyone present who
wishes to speak on this bill who has not
yet had the opportunity to do so so
seeing none I will recognize
representative Gilman to read out the
blue sheets thank you m Madam chair um
on the remote signing we had eight in
support and 35 in opposition on today's
blue sheet we have three in support and
two in
opposition thank you and with that that
I will close the public hearing on non
gerain Amendment 2025-the
I will open the public hearing on House
Bill 490 relative to indemnification for
municipalities adopting policies to
address
homelessness the chair recognizes
representative Howard to introduce the
bill and I um appreciate your patience
as we are behind schedule thank you
madam chairwoman uh no worries I'll make
it quick for everybody uh and also thank
you honorable committee members uh
homelessness has been a growing problem
in New New Hampshire and HP 490 is
enabling legislation that gives
municipalities additional tools to
combat this issue the problem the bill
is pretty simple uh as we all like to
say uh as it just removes liability from
Municipal properties being used as
shelters right now under current law if
a shelter were to be set up by a
municipality in a space that was not
fully suitable there are a number of
potential lawsuits that could arise for
example if a space did not have the
proper bathroom facilities or there was
not proper snow removal compare that to
their current living situation of uh the
woods or in people's backyards or on the
street and this is far more
preferable municipalities want to help
people get off the street but they are
worried about the potential consequences
of a lawsuit the worry that they have is
completely valid because whether it is
an ambulance Chaser or a legitimate
claim money that was not available to
upgrade or fix these shelters in the
first place would be redirected to any
damaged party under this bill legal
action against municipalities has to
prove that they were Beyond neglectful
uh and act with a conscious disregard
for the safety of others as long as
municipalities are trying to do the
right thing they will be protected if we
can pass this bill we can do a lot of
good help a lot of people and open more
shelter all through local control thank
you so much and I'm open to any
questions thank you representative um
representative Colby is recognized for a
question thank you madam chair thank you
representative Howard uh the majority of
municipalities have um Hazard mitigation
plans uh these plans define specific
public buildings that can be used as
temporary shelters um I noticed the term
temporary shelter uh being added here
would this also benefit
municipalities um and indemnify them
through
using yeah I mean that that's a good
point uh if I'm not mistaken in order to
be eligible for FEMA funding uh we
actually have to have some of these uh
uh things covered uh and make sure that
we actually have shelters available for
people in municipalities uh so having
this indemnification would really help
kind of cover a lot of those bases great
thank you further
questions representative Dolan thank you
madam chair uh thank you representative
for taking my question uh this
indemnification if if the homeless
shelter was set up and it was not per
code for fire
prevention and in the unfortunate s
situation a fire actually occurred and
and we had death and and injury as a
result would would that still be would
they still be indemnified or or not so I
I think that there would it would have
to be a case by case basis because uh as
if you can read uh section three of the
bill uh any action to recover damages
arising out of uh the appropriate
Authority uh C it can be taken up in
court as legal action and people can
make claims against the municipality
just there has to be proof that as I
said uh there has to be uh one second I
need to find this uh they have to
uh sorry they have
to here it is sorry apologies uh legal
election against municipalities has to
prove that they were Beyond neglectful
and act as with conscious disregard for
the safety of others so it's the fact
that they have to prove that they were
Beyond neglectful this means that they
were not necessarily uh doing everything
that they could to make sure that these
properties were uh as up to code as
possible and for the most part A lot of
the buildings that are being used they
are completely up to code it's just some
of the minor things like I had mentioned
with Stow removal where if we can get uh
if we don't necessarily have the proper
St removal out in front of these
shelters they can't legally be used uh
as there could be potential hazards for
like slipping on ice per se uh and if
somebody gets injured on our property
we're liable so it's just trying to
cover those bases so that we can try to
make sure that as many properties are
useful as Pro as possible I don't
necessarily know if there would be one
that would be used that wouldn't be up
to fire code but on the case that it was
I would potentially say uh it it depends
on the caseby casee scenario and whether
or not there was another shelter
available did meet those
codes representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question do you have a
definition of Beyond
neglect I uh I personally do not I again
I think that that's something where uh
if I think that the courts need to look
at that and kind of determine as I said
on a case-by Case
basis additional questions I have a
question I would assume that this is not
permitted right now um so this is a
totally new use for public property my
question is um with regards
to I understand that this bill would
allow municipalities to be able to
provide temporary shelter for
homeless so that would be food and and
housing on public property is there any
um Provisions for I guess oversight with
regards to health and safety of all of
those offerings or
Provisions I don't believe that there
are necessarily any in in that regard
it's just the fact that we do have a
number of shelters uh I mean for
instance I know that there are some
people from straford County we're going
to be speaking uh in a little bit about
the will and uh warming shelter and kind
of the situ that is going on there and I
mean that's a real world situation that
I think that they could provide a little
bit more information as to the need for
that uh and kind of what they are doing
to provide those services to make sure
that people are fed make sure that
people have access to the health care
that they need uh while they're
currently in those
shelters thank you further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much
next the chair recognizes Mr Nick
Taylor good uh morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government excent
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee I'm Nick Taylor I'm the
director of housing action New Hampshire
we are a Statewide organization that
advocates for pro housing policy and our
members include developers landlords
lenders property managers homeless
shelters and more um we appreciate the
intent we don't have a formal position
on this bill um and it only really kind
of came to our attention recently so I
apologize for not having a chance to
talk to the sponsor about this either
but so we appreciate the intent of what
we're trying to do here homelessness is
a major issue in New Hampshire the point
in time count has gone up by over 50%
from 2022 to
2023 and you know municipalities
certainly need in the state need more
tools to try and make this happen the
concerns that our members have Express
to us around this is um what the
representative brought up around code
and lowering safety standards that would
potentially put Folks at risk and that
this could create a situation where
there's essentially a race to the bottom
where you're using shelters and
structures that are not suitable for
folks to be living in and not safe and
that in our opinion can't be the answer
to addressing our homeless crisis is we
can't just say oh we've got an abandoned
building over here that doesn't have
bathrooms that isn't heated that may not
be up to code and let's go put folks
over there so we um you know they're out
of sight in some cases and again not
saying that's the intent necessarily
here but that is a concern that came up
about how this could be implemented
there have been a lot of really great
conversations and I believe even last
year around legislation around
innovative solutions pods temporary
structures these things that may be
outside of existing building code that
are sort of on the The Cutting Edge of
how do you provide a temporary shelter
in the midst of a crisis I think that
has a incredible amount of Merit to be
able to look at take a peak make sure
that our laws aren't preventing that or
mitigating risk there um but we do have
a lot of data on best practices for
addressing homelessness that includes
systems of care that includes person
Byers identification that includes
structures that provide health care that
includes being able to when folks are
getting sheltered have access to
additional resources in our opinion
that's the direction we should be going
on this rather than just opening up um
potentially unsafe environments but
again we don't have a formal position
and we'd be happy to work with the
sponsor and the committee on you know
any solutions if there is a agree upon
area moving forward and happy to take
questions questions for Mr
Taylor seeing none thank
you and and the last pin card that I
have is The Honorable Mr chuck chuck
grassy good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you madam chairperson
members of the committee um I'm Chuck
Rassy from the city of Rochester and I
introduced this bill last year uh and it
came before this committee and was sent
into from study
um I've been working for the last three
years with the straford county uh
committee on homelessness
and it's Faith Bas faith-based leaders
uh welfare directors from the local
communities and other individuals who
work in the homelessness issue and on
the policy committee which I served on
with the welfare directors from the
three cities in straford County uh we uh
we looking at what are the obstacles to
providing housing this is a very
complicated issue and we were looking
for something that we could do to be
meaningful to help communities address
housing this is not a replacement for
shelters real shelters that provides
services and safety and convenience for
those who are homeless we did a survey
in the straford County area and we found
that there were approximately 1400
people who are functionally unhoused
these are people who may be couch
surfing living in their cars living in
tents or boxes in the woods um or being
put up in hotels by the local
communities it's all most of it's very
expensive when we deal with homelessness
also as a farmer state representative I
used to receive numerous phone calls
from people who had homeless encampments
in their backyards or just beyond their
property in fact the biggest culprit
that I had here was uh Spalding tur Pike
runs through Rochester and it runs
through my district and I would get
calls from people saying that they're
behind my house and I've got an
encampment there and they're leaving
trash all over the place what can I do I
call the City of Rochester and they say
it's on State
Property well the thing is is yeah it's
on state property but there's no nobody
there to move them off that property and
when we do move them off that property
all we do is we chase them to another
piece of property in somebody else's
backyard if a municipality has a piece
of land that may be available where they
can set up their
tents why aren't we able to use that I
served on the city council in Rochester
for over 20 years served with
representative WKA here for many years
and we looked at solutions for many
problems and if you're a city councilman
or a board of selectman member when you
have approach where your your town
administrator or city manager may come
in and
say we've got a piece of land that we'd
like to use that maybe we can move these
homeless people to it may be a park that
hasn't been used much or an area or even
a parking lot that isn't being used or
behind an a building or maybe it's a
vacant building that you
have I would look at my administrator
and and and my manager and I would say
what are our liabilities and he said
well he would say he or she would say if
somebody gets hurt we're probably going
to get sued and I would say nope not
going there because I don't want to put
my taxpayers in situation of having
lawsuits that could cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars to the taxpayers if
somebody was to be
injured these people are currently
living in the woods let's start with
that
proposition when we met as a policy
committee the directors of plan the
welfare directors of Rochester Dover
summersworth the housing administrator
and in Dover as well um we talked about
that these people are living in the
woods right now they're living in boxes
they're living in tents they're living
under
tarps communities have land that may be
a better case place for them to
be we may have a vacant garage which we
can make
safe what it says in the
bill is that employee if employees
intentionally act to create harm or risk
of harm or acted with a conscious
disregard for the safety of
others then we're responsible but if we
don't meet that
criteria then we should be held harmless
if a community decides to provide an
opportunity straford county has the war
Willard warming Center and what happened
there is that we they were licensed
basically to have 80 people in the
center and I know I met with the city
manager of the city of Dover and he went
in and he said you know we've got a lot
of people I went in and looked like a
military Barracks quite honestly there
were bunk beds people were living in
them people were sleeping in them in the
evenings but they weren't there during
the day time they had their stuff stored
and he said you know this is unsafe you
got stuff that's stored here overnight
we're not supposed to have anything here
stored overnight what do these people
supposed to do with their stuff
particularly if they're going to a
job and then when they got to a point
where they had maybe 12 people show up
on a very cold
evening some of them were pitching their
tent on the grounds
that wasn't unsafe it was very safe it
was safer than being where they where
they were out in the woods or in
somebody's backyard causing A disruption
to the people who own that property this
was a bill that was a simple approach to
allow communities to address the
situations for temporary places for
shelter while they're dealing with it
you get many communities particularly
small communities it's not in their
budget to put up a homeless shelter a
lot of times they send them to the
cities and the Cities end up with them
living on the streets or living in in
people's
backyards and in drafting this bill I
felt this was a way to approach the
situation to provide opport so that
there wasn't a
roadblock to a community saying we can
do something here it's not perfect but
it's a
start I'll be happy to answer any
questions thank you other
questions seeing none thank you
so at this time I would ask is there
anyone present who wishes to speak on
this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none the
chair recognizes representative Gilman
to report out the blue sheets thank you
madam chair on the uh remote sign in we
had 135 in support and eight in
opposition and on today's blue sheet we
have one in
support thank you and with that the
chair will close the public hearing on
House Bill
490 so if there are people wishing to
provide testimony and you have your pink
cards please um pass them
forward for
s
sorry
spe
we are slightly behind schedule and I
appreciate your patience
um we had a lot of people wanting to
testify so at this time I the chair will
open the public hearing on House Bill
668 FN local authorizing municipalities
to hold a referendum to resend the
licenses of historic horse racing
facilities at this time the chair
recognizes representative M the prime
sponsor to introduce the bill to the
committee good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning Madam chair and good morning to
the representatives of the committee uh
you've heard my first bill which is to
uh allow an optin and this is this this
is the other uh part of the process to
allow and opt out this bill is
essentially a tool in your toolbox to
deal with possible problems in your
community what the bill does is gives
local control
over Casino
locations if you like your casino at
your location you can keep it if you
don't like it you can ask them to move
or you can shut them
down so why do we need this
bill well as I mentioned previously
cities and towns were never allowed to
have an optin vote on casinos in your
local city and
town the bill that allowed
the historic horse racing machines was a
very simple Bill and said that you if
you have a charitable gaming license you
can apply for a HHR license which turns
out to be slot
machines okay now in the past and
various Casino bills that Ways and Means
had worked on if you wanted to do
expanded gaming you're required to have
a referendum by the city and town the
state will allow it but you the city and
town you the municipality
have that decision to take it or leave
it not available in this uh current
legislation that allow the HHR
machines so these tend to be very
profitable devices if you have slot
machines and other jurisdictions you
typically have a very large license fee
in NE of 25 million bucks to 80 million
bucks just to have a license to have
these type of machines
Massachusetts we charge
nothing 250
bucks um in other jurisdictions if you
have these machines there's a pretty
considerable tax on
these in Massachusetts if you if you buy
a license for 25 million bucks you're
subject to a 49%
tax here in New
Hampshire we have to give
25% to the state and to Charities and
the oper keep keeps
75% pretty generous so now you have an
Enterprise that has um non-existent
license fee a very high margin and the
ability to put slot machines wherever
they want
them so what's
happening well what's happening is the
mom and pop operators in charitable
gaming lucky moose in Nashville where I
live sell out to the big investors
because they're saying well geez I can
put in a slot C know with very little
expense to do it and very good terms if
I put it in I pay roughly five and 3/4%
to Charities under state law the rest is
split to the
lottery um a pretty good deal so the mom
and pop operators was sing out to the
big investors ecl
entertainment um Delaware North large
out ofate corporations no problem
because they have a lot of capital and
they use that Capital
to put these licenses into a much bigger
building in my case I live in
nashille the Feather Lane mall is a main
shopping center Sears is one of the five
big stores there they they're on of
business that's
vacant so Sears gets bought
out and now we have a casino coming in
that'll be opening next month
it'd be over a thousand
Machines of same square footage and
it'll attract a big
crowd
so what's the impact on the local
folks I spent 10 weeks
campaigning and I asked people what
their concerns are and I'm sure there're
the concerns that you've heard from your
constituents which is property
taxes we've had a snap revaluation in
ashaa
our typical property which is in the
order of 4 100,000 now has gone up
100,000
valuation and that caused their tax
bill to go up about a th000
bucks so we're pretty unhappy about the
property taxes in nville and I'm sure
your cities and towns are feeling the
same
way so then they asked me well what are
we going to do about it
well I said well we got this big Casino
coming up in The Fez Lane
Mall can they do something for
us no they're not
required the best we can do is say well
we want to be one of the Charities maybe
we can get a piece of the action maybe
you know one half of 10 days a year for
some mitigation maybe
$100,000 I would point out that in other
Casino bills that we
had there was a lot of thought given to
mitigation by the host Community our
communities that mitigation was in the
form of 5% off the
top we don't have that it's not in the
horse racing
Bill the casino operators have no
obligation to give anything to the
cities and
towns besides they very modest property
tax and a m in at the pH Lan mall for
example it's
$118,000 on the current valuation you
know for business that's going to put
out $24 million to charity 20 million to
charity 200,000 to the city of nasua
seems a little
unbalanced so what I'm suggesting is
that we set ourselves up to a bit of
negotiation um shouldn't we have a tool
in our tool box that says if you're not
treating us right and this would be
voluntary there's no statutory
obligation to do anything for the city
and towns but if you're not treating us
right so we have in our toolbox that
says you know we enjoyed being here for
three years but now your license is
coming up for
Renewal and you know our citizens are
kind of concerned about property taxes
the cost we have to pay for schools
which is most our property tax and
you're not doing anything for us
so maybe we should
negotiate now if you don't have any
tools to negotiate well good luck if you
have a tool that says you don't want to
talk to
us we're going to put out a
referendum and see what the folks think
and see if the people who are unhappy
about their property taxes and see this
casino with the traffic any other issues
which is documented in this long handout
that
maybe we don't want you anymore and
we'll say thanks for your three years
but uh time to move
on so let me talk a little bit about the
cost of crime in
casinos this document is a 20-year
study of every count every county in the
United States excuse me representative
on could could you focus your testimony
on the is issue of the um opt out
provision I and focus on that and
because we do have a lot of pink cards
so if you could Target your testimony
and seek to um finish up having laid the
foundation for the out
provision the provision is is that uh
the city and town has the
right to call a
referendum and as to whether
this Enterprise this horse racing Casino
shall be allowed to stay or
not the bill says that if we choose to
either the citizens with a 5% vote of
the people in
town or the town
administrators can call a referendum and
ask do we want to have
this casino license
remain in
place or do we want to have it
revoked that's the
tool I hope you consider some of the
reasons for having that tool and the
choice is
yours thank you madam chairman thank you
other
questions representative Colby thank you
madam chair just a really quick question
uh if a municipality were to vote favor
of prohibition while there is an
existing operation in place how much
notice uh would the municipality be
required to give to the owner
operator yeah that's specified in the
statute uh for
referendums um and that's an excellent
question because you can't shut down an
existing business you can only shut down
the
license
um the timeing on this is at the annual
Town
meetings so when you have your votes for
your budget this would be part of that
process and it would not be retroactive
it would be prospective when the license
comes up for Renewal and this referenda
passes that license shall not be renewed
in that
jurisdiction further
questions I had a quick question so um
with regards
to I guess gambling or um this casino
licensing is there a separate license
for like the casino for example like the
what is it called the the what moose the
lucky moose in nashaa right so there's a
separate license for that operation and
then is it correct that there's a
separate license for
HHR uh the license for the lucky moose
is
$250 and they can apply to have historic
op racing which they have and were
granted so you have a chable gaming
operation card games
standard you know Blackjack and uh hold
them
tournaments you were allowed to apply
for a license for expanding that
historic
racing and 14 of the chable gaming
establishments were qualified for
that so a followup is is this this bill
pertains just to that secondary license
to allow HHR it wouldn't be shutting
down the entire operation it's just that
it's just that particular game yes CH
yes the uh the facilities that have HHR
machines would be shut
down if they don't have HHR they're not
going to be
effective representing a frock
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so I I assume that
these slot machines cost a considerable
amount of money to the owner of the
casino um if they lose their license
would they have a claim of in essence
taking unlawfully taking of their
property I would be skeptical on that
first these machines are tend to be
least rather than
purchased if they are purchased they
have a license for 3 years to operate
these
machines they're not guaranteed Beyond
three
years for these machines they made a
business decision as to what to invest
how long they can have them and what
kind of profit they can make to pay for
that Enterprise beyond that would be
speculation uh thank you that answers my
question further
questions seeing none thank thank
you next the chair recognizes Ms Alicia
Preston good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning Madam chair members of the
committee thank you I am Alisha Preston
I represent the New Hampshire charitable
gaming operators Association we are here
in opposition of this bill as it was
just indicated it would resend the
rights of existing businesses to
continue practicing
businesses for your information there
are 14 historic horse racing licenses in
the state 11 are operational there are
five more in the application process it
caps out at that there are no other
applications allowed to be accepted by
the state of New Hampshire until 2031 so
there is already a limit on this these
11 operating and the three that are
building out have spent millions of
dollars in order to have the space the
time and the facilities to operate
historic horse racing some do buy them
some do lease them and they have
long-term contracts but if you were to
look at where these physical businesses
were and what they looked like before
the authorization of historic horse
racing 2021 you would see the incredible
amounts of money these operators have
put in to make it a full gaming
experience if a town were to resin their
right to practice they would absolutely
lose an enormous amount of money that
had they have given to New Hampshire and
to of course the hundreds of Charities
that benefit from HHR just in December
so that you know that's the recent
numbers I have uh the state received 2.5
million in revenue from historic horse
raising and Charities received 1.4
million and for those reasons we are
opposed to this bill and I'm happy to
answer any
questions thank you
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes miss an
fera did I say that right you did good
perfect good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you all for taking the time and allowing
us to come in and speak on this I'm from
New Hampshire soccer association the
executive director and I'm speaking in
an opposition of this bill uh New
Hampshire soccer association provides
inclusive soccer programming including
our adaptive soccer program for children
with disabilities charity gaming has
been essential in allowing us to offer
scholarships and reduce Financial
barriers ensuring all children can
participate we strongly oppose the bill
668 as Oppo as losing this funding would
severely impact their ability to support
children's physical and mental
well-being limiting access of positive
activities and excluding families from
participating in programs that they rely
on and I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Edwin
Smith
good morning sir and welcome to
Municipal and County
government good morning Madam chair
members of the committee I feel somewhat
like an old home day because I was a
former legislature legislator and 12
years were spent in this room so I I it
looks familiar you haven't changed much
in here except the microphones we had to
speak louder
then I represent
after my after my legislative
engagement I still continue to help the
applications for charity gaming our
state forms once you filled out one it's
easy to fill out two three and four so I
do four of them and I'm here to tell you
about two of them and what the benefits
are from the charity gaming that they
have received uh the spford Lake
Association
is a popular destination in New
Hampshire spford Lake association's
mission is to protect enhance and
sustain the ecological environmental and
recreational character of spford lake
and the surrounding Watershed the spford
Lake Association provides Lake host
checking incoming boats for invasive
plants they also check the water water
quality of the lake on a regular basis
being proactive rather than reactive
they provide weed Watchers to check the
lake for invas plant plants watershed
management for helping to prevent the
degra degra degradation of the
degradation of the quality of the water
volunteers to assist to the New
Hampshire Department of Public Works and
Recreation with activities on Pierce
island and just out of note Pierce
island is the smallest state park in the
state of New Hampshire it's just about
an acre and it's in the middle of the
lake so the volunteers for spford Lake
take care of that or help the state with
that and they also work got to receive a
Federal grant to do a storm water
quality runoff study and with the town
of Chesterfield they have got a new
ordinance in Chesterfield concerning
runoff to the lake the lake is a very
important part of the recreation in the
state in in that western part of
southwestern part of the
state and then the one of the other
groups I help is the SP the hensdale
Lions Club and we proba provide Aid to
various groups sponsoring a Boy Scout
Troop baseball teams free eyesight
screening for kids prek through fifth
grade that's an interesting thing too we
do about 300 screenings and 10% of those
kids need glasses of some sort or need
some attention at least a further
examination and the Lions Club pays for
that if if they can't afford it in the
family but 10% of the students that go
through there have a problem that needs
further further
investigation we also also have uh a
program called 68 hours of hunger which
the high school sponsors but we're one
of the sponsors for the high school have
scholarships for the students and we
provide sand for the seniors and winter
to provide to prevent falling on Ice we
also provide holiday and meal baskets
and Thanksgiving and Christmas based on
what the town recommends so we're sort
of the the go-to for the town if they
run into having money problems in in
addition we provide cash donations for
families who provide experience who have
who experience catastrophic losses such
as a
fire and we
provide the quality of life for
residents in an economically depressed
town the southwestern corner of New
Hampshire um I am in district 15 I
haven't met by representative but I
understand he's here so it's a pleasure
to meet you
sir it's actually my dad your dad okay
yeah okay you're not District well I
haven't met my representative yet I
will that's all I have to say I'll keep
it as brief as I have which was a little
long thank you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so M um fera you you indicated that
you had written testimony did
you yeah but you you don't really okay
next the chair recognizes Ms Michelle
Ali good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning and thank you so much for having
us here today um my name is Michelle Ali
I am the CEO of Webster house Children's
Home in Manchester New Hampshire and I
reside in nashille New Hampshire I'm
testifying in opposition of HB 668 for
the past
141 years since 1884 the Webster house
has been providing a safe supportive
home for children unable to live at home
for reasons of abuse neglect addiction
homelessness and other challenges in the
community we are contracted with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and have children between the ages of 8
and 18 living at the house who are
primarily referred to us through
DCF we nurture these at risk youth
through trauma informed care we provide
stability and structure while rebuilding
self-esteem confidence and independent
living skills we take the kids to school
appointments fun social activities
celebrate birthdays graduations and
holidays with them like we do with our
own
children we have children that have
lived with us for eight years they age
out and they have no one to go to they
rely on us as their family based on our
contract with the state we receive a
daily rate for the children in our care
which covers only half of our expenses
that said is it is critical that we
close the funding Gap with revenue
streams including grants individual and
corporate donations and thankfully
charitable gaming
funds the charitable gaming funds are
critical to the Webster house they help
us provide the highest level of care for
our residents who deserve a second
chance give them a home filled with
healthy food appropriate clothing and
all of the basic needs that build their
trust happiness confidence and enable
them to thrive These funds are well
established in our budget and very very
grateful for these funds and we rely on
them to close this funding Gap any
Revenue loss from charitable gaming will
would hurt us and the many I believe
it's 800 organizations that serve those
in need eliminating any of this funding
would significantly impact our operation
and would mean we would have to
eliminate some of the initiatives that
positively impact our children
charitable gaming has provided much
needed Revenue to organizations like the
Webster house making them an essential
component of our state's so social
safety net we rely on these funds HB
668 would put Charities like ours at
risk I strongly urge you to reject HB
668 and protect our charitable Gaming
Community losing those funds would be
harmful to our organization and hurt
those who we serve thank you for your
consideration are there any questions
thank you Miss Al
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Miss Susan
Holland it's still morning so good
morning and welcome to Municipal and
County government good morning thank you
madam chair and hello distinguished
members of the committee I am Susan
Howland and I am the vice president of
community relations and development for
the mental health center of Greater
Manchester
um at the mental health center of
Greater Manchester we provide a wide
variety of services for people who are
having mental health and substance
misuse challenges um we serve um
critical services to to individuals
across our region many of whom are who
are among the most vulnerable members of
our society I stand before you today to
strongly oppose the house bill
668 uh to allow referendums to resend
the licenses to the historic horse
racing which is an important part of
charitable gaming for nonprofit
organizations particularly those like
ours who have dedicated to ensuring that
individual individuals with mental
health and substance misuse challenges
receive the care that they need
regardless of their ability to pay as
many of you are aware New Hampshire's
Community Mental Health Centers had an
unprecedented challenges as a result of
the Medicaid unwind uh the center I work
for is no exception of course as a
safety net provider we provide services
to people who are eligible to receive
care under our administrative rules
regardless of their ability to pay this
results in a large uncompensated care
balance every year as a nonprofit
organization we must continue to seek
funding so that we continue to provide
quality Care chairville gaming has been
a vital component to our fundraising
efforts over the years in fact in the
last two years we have brought in just
over $150,000
through this partnership which means a
lot to the patients that we serve this
allows us to help defund essential
mental health and substance misuse
services and programs that our community
depends upon these funds are aimed at
two major challenges that our state is
facing and has been facing mental health
and substance misuse the people we serve
are already facing systematic barriers
to care and eliminating this funding
mechanism would only deepen these
inequality inequities thank you are
there any questions for me
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes M Amy
hollingworth and it's still morning so
good morning and welcome to Municipal
and County government thank you very
much my name is Amy hollingworth and I
represent New Hampshire muscular
skeletal Institute
a nonprofit dedicated to ensuring young
athletes in New Hampshire have Equitable
access to essential sports medicine
services and I'm testifying in
opposition to houseal houseal Bill
668 this bill could threaten Charities
like mine who benefit from the
charitable B gaining funds the save
Sports Network which is nhmi largest
program provides free athletic healthc
care to Manchester public school
athletes charitable Gab Revenue has been
critical to sustaining these services
and ensuring children can participate in
sports safely um and reach their full
potential on and off the field for many
years New Hampshire nonprofits have
relied on charitable gaming to fund
essential programs House Bill 668
threatens that
support if passed this bill could lead
to reduced Gaming revenue cutting
essential funding for nonprofits
Statewide for us that means fewer
athletic trainers reduced Injury Care
access and increased health risks for
student athletes so I urge you to reject
House Bill 668 and protect New
Hampshire's charitable Gaming Community
thank you for your time and
consideration thank you
questions seeing none thank you the
final pin card that I have here today is
representative
Aly good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County Government
good morning thank you for being
late I was yanked off but
on I want to testify on behalf of this
bill and I come from the city of Lebanon
the city of Lebanon was uh a lot of us
uh did not do not approve of spending
money that should be used for your home
budget
Etc uh on gambling we've had experience
of people that uh were in important
positions that ended up
on uh I think one of them in jail uh
because they stole from the organization
that they were working for um because
they were addicted to
gambling
and I rather regard our current position
as that we are funding part of our
government on
addiction of those
people that are not capable of stopping
gambling once they've been been addicted
to it we have almost no money and we
have no uh even board left that in the
uh the Lottery Commission there is
supposed to be a board connected to it
which is doing problem
gambling and uh I think it was three of
the four people who were on it have
resigned at this point and there is
really nothing else in the state except
individuals going out and trying to talk
to other individuals
um we we stand pretty much with
Littleton on this both of us were given
casinos without uh knowing what we were
getting into in our case it was a a
charitable gaming group that was started
for poker uh by someone who knew that
the bill was likely going to pass at one
point or another
and um it's now a major Casino uh across
from our cheapest best
supermarket and AC and down one building
from the our major thrift store which
funds a lot of our poverty
initiatives the people in that
uh on store thrift store or and the
people people who run
listen uh have said that they didn't
want to ask for any of that money
because they are seeing too much damage
since it
moved uh before it moved when it was a
small Poker Palace that they put a lot
of machines in um on too much damage to
their clients who are incapable of
stopping and also Inc capable of funding
their families or their housing or their
food so
um I feel pretty strongly about this
individually I I know for sure that the
city of Lebanon would have voted this
down 15 years ago I don't know if it
would now uh but I do think that that
other towns ought to have the chance to
decide whether they want that in their
town or not
not thank you thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you so this
was the last pink card that I have and
I'd like to ask at this time is there
anyone present who wishes to speak on
this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do
so seeing none the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets thank you madam chair under
under the remote signin we had three in
support and 11 opposed
and on the uh today's blue sheet we have
one in
favor thank you and with that the chair
will close the public hearing on House
Bill 668 FN
local time is it so miraculously we got
back on schedule it is now 12:01
according to my iPad and not the clock
on the wall so at this time we will take
lunch for an hour and we will re come
back here at 1
to um exec a number of bills have a nice
lunch
e
e e
so we have some um amendments being
passed around and I'll give everybody a
couple of minutes to sort themsel out
and get organized
e
e e
okay when everybody's ready just look at
me
so I know you're
ready e
good afternoon at this time the
committee will begin executive session
on bills that we heard
previously and the clerk is ready so at
this time I will open the executive
session on House Bill 230 local relative
to the adoption of Public Health
ordinances by
municipalities the chair recognizes
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman so I would like to recom
amend um Amendment
202527782 House Bill 230 um and if
there's a second I'll be happy to speak
to it is there a second I'll second that
thank you representative Murphy seconds
that representative major would you like
to speak to the amendment yes thank you
very much so um after our public hearing
um I appreciate the chair working uh
working with the sponsor uh and myself
to try to work through the details of
this bill which to uh which to some this
bill we've seen many many times before
um and we just try to get to a point
where we have something that that
satisfies everybody and we can finally
uh put behind us uh lock it up into
statute and our conversation was that we
should with RSA 147 uh colon one create
the guard rails to what health officers
can do per the order ordinance and we
think it leaving it too um as in their
for the removal of nuisances as in their
judgment the health and safety of the
people require puts a guardrail because
the statute again is specific to
nuisances I had a wonderful conversation
with the sponsor of the bill
representative Harvey bolia to talk
about the potential to work together
then in an additional year about giving
the health officers than the same kind
of latitude that that currently exists
but they were curtailing bit but to give
them that Latitude in their communities
for the things that may come up
something is going to come up that does
not fit neatly into a bucket that does
not fit neatly into a statute and how
can we address that and I appreciate the
willingness of the sponsor to uh to work
on that so with that I recommend that
the or I suggest that this bill puts the
necessary guard rails still gives enough
enough latitude for uh Health officers
to be able to do their jobs and and with
that I would hope that everyone can also
agree whoops look he's
stuck thank you is there any discussion
on the
amendment no seeing none then the motion
before us is to accept Amendment
2025-the
yes if you are opposed to the amendment
then you will vote no the clerk will
call the role
Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes repres representative grund
yes Madam chair
yes the vote on Amendment
d2770 um passes with a vote of 18 to
zero do I have a
motion represent yeah M chairwoman I
would like to move otpa on House Bill 23
local with Amendment well with the
amendment yes otpa is there a second
I'll second that thank you
representative Murphy seconds that is
there any
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Elward yes the clerk votes
yes representative France yes
representative Kosinski yes
representative
Murphy yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative jamna
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Zer the committee recommendation on
House Bill 230 local is ought to pass
with Amendment without objection that
will go on to the house consent calendar
and the report author will be
representative majority thank
you and with that the executive session
on House Bill 230 local is now closed
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 689 enabling
municipalities to adopt a volunteer
incentive property tax credit
the chair is do I have a motion the
chair recognizes represent FR yes I'd
like to make a motion to for inexpedient
to legislate for HB 689 thank you is
there a second I'll second that uh was
that representative Gerard thank you is
there discussion
okay so the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
689 if you are in favor um of it Ling
the bill you'll vote Yes if you are
not in favor of an expedient legislate
then you'll vote
no okay why are people looking at me
oh oh some people are still thinking oh
I I I I did make a mistake I'm sorry did
I ask if you would like to speak to the
motion I think I skipped that step I
skipped it does any I'm sorry does
anybody is there any discussion or
debate okay so the motion is
itl I should look at my script
okay the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France yes
representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to zero therefore the committee
recommendation on House
Bill 689 is inexpedient to legislate and
without objection that will go on the
house consent
calendar and representative France will
you write the
report thank you
so next the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill 76 six
enabling municipalities to adopt an
exemption from the local education
property tax for certain elderly
residents Madam chair I'd like to make a
motion yes uh house bills 766 and
expedient to legislate is there a second
second representative Walker seconds
that would you like to speak to your
motion
no is there any um
discussion
right so the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
766 if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the role
Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie
no representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy yes
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 17
to1 the committee recommendation on
House Bill
766 is inexpedient to legislate and
without objection that will go on the
house consent
calendar and representative Kosinski
will write the report thank you thank
you
okay and with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill 766
at this time I will open the executive
session on house bills 625 relative to
enabling municipalities to Levy payments
against nonprofit profits at a
percentage of their assessed property
values do I have a motion the chair
recognizes representative stavis thank
you madam chair I would like to um
suggest voting itl on HP 625 thank you
is there a second Madame chair I like to
second that thank you representative
Murphy seconds that representative
stavis would you like to speak to your
motion thank you thank you madam chair
just very briefly uh this bill has the
potential to upend and confuse many
decades of success successfully
implemented pilot payments between
municipalities and nonprofit
organizations of all
kinds Is there further discussion or
comments seeing none the clerk will call
the
role by chairman McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes represent representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative ger
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grundt yes Madam
chair yes
the motion passes with a vote of 18 to Z
the committee recommendation on House
Bill 625 is inexpedient to legislate and
without objection that will be placed on
the house consent
calendar and the report will be written
by representative stavis thank
you and with that the executive session
on House Bill 625 is now closed
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 147 relative to
clarifying tax exemptions for properties
used by religious educational and
charitable organizations
the do I have a motion M chairman yep
the chair recognizes Vice chairman
McDonald for a motion I move to ought to
pass is there a second Madam chair I'll
second that thank you representative
Murphy seconds that rep um Vice chairman
mcdonal would you like to speak to your
motion yeah just a minute uh this bill
further clarifies the tax exemptions for
properties uh by religious educational
and cheal organization which is well
needed at this time thank you thank
you are there any further comments or
[Music]
discussion representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman
um so we uh it seemed like it was a
reasonable idea when we first heard the
bill and then as more information came
uh as we learn more information there is
a bill that's almost identical that's
going through the Senate right now
um and as we learned more information
the current language in statute came as
a recommendation from a study bill to
clarify ambiguous language and the
intent of this bill would be to take us
not the intent but the result of this
bill would be to take us back to what
was considered ambiguous language so uh
for those simple for for those reasons
um I object the ought to pass and would
hope that rather than an itl we might be
able to get to um a point of retaining
so that we can figure out what is
actually the best language to have in
here because I don't object to what they
want to do I just think that we need to
have a better way to get there so thank
you further comments discussion
representative stavis thank you madam
chair I would agree with my colleague
that this his bill would be better
retained than passed um
as a resident of Lebanon New Hampshire
and neighboring Hanover New Hampshire we
are surrounded by educational charitable
nonprofit
organizations that own vast tracts of
land within our
municipalities um and sometimes the
activities conducted on those tracts of
lands do not comport with their missions
and it is extremely difficult to make
those distinctions and I I do believe
that this bill bill makes it even more
difficult to make those
distinctions further
comments so I had one comment as I
recall during the hearing the primes and
I do acknowledge what represented
majority said um with the language
that's in statute but I I do believe
that I recall that the prime sponsor had
explained that in in recent times um the
interpretation is not being interpreted
properly and therefore she felt the need
to um clarify the language so that the
statute was being applied um as the
legislative in
intent um was in the bill so I just
wanted to add that as a
comment further
comments seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 147 if
you are in favor of the motion then
you'll vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion then you will vote no the
clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk vote Yes representative
France yes
representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
no Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 147 will be ought to pass
representative McDonald will you write
the report yes
and will there be any other
reports okay represented majority will
write The Minority Report thank
you and that will go on the regular
calendar and with that the chair will
close the executive session on on House
Bill
147 at this time the chair opens the
executive session on how spill
426 relative to property tax exemptions
for charitable organizations for the
prior tax
year Madam chairman yes I'd like to move
to adopt uh Amendment 2025
0141 uh to House Bill
426 is there a
second second representative majority
seconds that would you like to speak to
your motion to adopt the amendment
representative McDonald thank you um
this amendment came as a result of
conversations with the
uh view of land and tax appeal uh made
some additional modifications and made
the uh the bill I believe a little bit
better uh as far as they're concerned
and the enforcement of the uh the bill
itself thank
you any um comments
discussion so um I have a
comment so I looked I I do I'm not
against the intent of the bill but as I
continued to look at the bill and and
especially the amendment I do
acknowledge that the amendment um fixes
some incorrect dates that the bill um as
filed had in it but I have I do have a
con concern with I I I feel
that the language here in the amendment
which replaces um section one of the
bill it doesn't quite do perhaps what
the prime sponsor is hoping that the
bill will will do and I would also say
that the reason why we have um House
Bill
426 was because 2024 House Bill 1055
there again
so there's the intent of the bill um and
I think that what was missed is that any
um bill that affects local property
taxes the effective date shall be April
1st of the following year and and there
were some I
guess questions as to oh why well why
was that um effective date that well
that's a statutory requirement so that
answers that so but because of that
because of what was trying to be done in
1055 the original bill um and because of
that effective date that's why we have
this um second bill in the amendment and
the concern is
that on the last line nine it references
RSA
7234 a and my understanding is that
appeals must be done by September
1st
and furthermore my concern is is that
the way that this amendment is written
that there's really no time limit that
somebody can come back and you know
request an adjustment so so that's a
concern because it seems like it's just
going to throw
um deadlines out out the window so I I
won't um I won't go on but I I'm opposed
to the
amendment
and therefore yeah we'll we'll just take
the vote on
this is there any other comments I'd
like to respond yeah uh thank you madam
chairman this is one thing we can really
do the right thing just think if you're
a nonprofit and in 8 months you have a
choice of not paying 25 or 30 or 50,000
in taxes because the law is going to
change uh this this clearly identifies
this is for the
2024 tax year and right now if if people
go in and say I'm I'm Ling my taxes I
can't give any excuse the selectman just
say that's too bad you owe 20 grand or
15 grand or whatever it is this gives
them the opportunity to go into the
board of Selectmen and explain why
they're late that's all it does it
doesn't say you're going to get your
taxes you don't have to pay your taxes
or whatever it gives them the
opportunity to go in and be
heard and I think they least deserve
that thank
you further
comments so seeing none the motion
before us is to accept Amendment
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis yes
representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
no Representative grund
no chairman power no
the motion to accept the amendment
passes with a vote of
15-3 do I have a motion a sec another
motion representa
McDonald yes I move uh otpa is there a
second I'll second the motion
representative majority seconds that
representative uh Vice chairman McDonald
would you like to speak to your motion
no thank you okay is there any um
comments okay representative
grund so one of my concerns about this
is setting precedence
to each year someone comes back and asks
again and again and I do understand the
concern over maybe a a MISD but I do I
am concerned on this one um and the idea
of a retrospective bill um in the New
Hampshire Constitution part one article
23 retrospective built laws are highly
injures oppressive and unjust and no
such laws therefore shall be made for
either decision of civil causes or
punishment offenses is a concern of
looking back on dates
represent uh Vice chairman
McDonald thank you uh i' just like to uh
talk about the retrospective laws uh
there's a couple of court cases New
Hampshire Court cases Norton versus
Patton 125 New Hampshire
413 and State versus Belo
125 New Hampshire
304 um much like you I do some research
on some of the cases and I don't have
access to a uh a lot of uh case Maxs but
I would look up all the cases so use
Google and what these cases basically
found was uh constitutional Hampshire
Constitution retrospective laws the
provisions in the hamster Constitution
for excuse me forbidding retrospective
or post-facto laws prohibits the
enactment of any laws which create a new
obligation impose a new Duty or attaches
a new disability in respect to
transactions already passed this bill
does none of that okay when you think of
something like that that it's like if
I'm sitting in prison for burglary and
they changed the burglar law I'm sitting
there for seven years and I say now I
get a s there for 10 years that's what
that is this does nothing this bill does
nothing like this it's actually to help
help the nonprofits it's not penalizing
them or giving this disabled or any of
that other things uh so at this time I
don't believe that the rospective law uh
applies to
this thank you representative Dolan
thank you uh mam chair
uh question my colleague uh
representative McDonald my is it isn't
my my understanding that this is a
one-time look back to
2024 yes it is correct thank
you further
comments again I I I understand the
intent of the bill but I I I maintain my
position that the the wording in this
bill as amended just doesn't
accomplish what the intent is that's
just my
opinion so um the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
426 if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no clerk will
call the role
Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
yes representative Alward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
no representative
grund yes
Madam chair
no so the motion passes with a vote of
16-2 and the committee recom
recommendation on House Bill
426 will be ought to pass with
Amendment
oh hold
on with without objection that will go
on the consent calendar is there any
objection seeing none it will go on the
consent
calendar and um representative
Vice chairman McDonald you'll write the
report is that correct thank
you will I'll I'll ask will there be a
Minority
Report
no so with that um the chair will close
the executive session on House Bill 426
chair will now open the executive
session on House Bill 6117 relative to
the homestead
right representative Murphy is
recognized for a motion Madame chair I'd
like to
uh uh opening up the u z yeah 2025
d437 H Amendment and ought to pass with
the amendment
okay thank you um
is there a
second representative Dolan seconds that
is there would you like to speak to your
motion representative Murphy on the
amendment to accept the amendment not at
this
time is there any discussion on the
amendment everybody has the amendment
correct yes you were supposed to look at
me
yes representive
majority uh thank you madam chairwoman I
I the amendment does seem to answer one
of the questions that we had in
committee which is to allow the trust to
claim the exemp the exemption so I am
supportive of this amendment but we'll
only speak to obviously we're only
talking about the amendment so I'm
supportive of that because this is one
of the questions that was
raised and it answers the question
further comments or
discussion so um to to reiterate that
this amendment reflects as you recall
during the hearing the prime sponsor had
noted that when she submitted the
language to OS for the LSR that somehow
the provision with regards to trust
somehow got dropped lost and never made
it into the
bill so further comments
okay seeing seeing none the motion
before us is to accept the amendment
d437 if you are in favor of accepting
the amendment you will vote Yes if you
are not in favor of accepting the
amendment you will vote no the clerk
will call the role on the amendment
Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yeah
representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis yes
yes representative Gilman
yes representative majori
yes representative
frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative Jama
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes Madam chair yes
the motion to accept the amendment
passes with a vote of 18 to Zer is there
another
motion I like to make a motion Madam
chair like make motion to accept it as
amended how spill 617 and representative
Dolan you you just seconded that so
thank you so the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment
representative Murphy would you like to
speak to your motion not at this
time are there any
comments representative
majority thank you m chairwoman uh so
while supportive of the amendment
because I do think the amendment makes
the bill better um we heard numerous
times in committee even from the prime
sponsor and from testimony that we
received from the prime sponsor that the
million dollars is probably not the
right number and the number should be
more like half a million dollars I mean
that's even in the we have from the from
the attorney so I'm not I don't oppose
to increasing it but I don't see any
evidence to where a million dollars is
the right number and in fact to the
again to the contrary where I see a half
a million dollars is is probably the
right number um so it's one of those
things where I I I just don't it just
doesn't seem like I have the evidence to
support the bill as it has been
presented thank you further comments
representative stavis thank you madam
chair and I feel not qualified to speak
to this and since I wasn't at the
hearing but in reviewing the bill
afterwards I have some questions about
definitions that I don't believe were
answered uh in the hearing because I've
asked and one of them is what is the
definition of a housing
cooperative and that is in line eight of
the bill um it is is nowhere defined I
can't find any reference to it in
existing law I don't know what it
is so I while I'm supportive of the
amendment I can't support the bill
further
comments representative grund one of the
other concerns I remember was talking
was brought up about um home housing
cooperatives which I think is what
you're talking about and it was
referenced as HOAs and there was the
concern about whether percentage of land
in an HOA is now attached and things so
I am opposed to this bill for that
reason without clarification
representative
stavis um thank you representative grund
and Madam chair with respect to
homeowners associations this could be a
disastrous bill because it it while it
is true that in an HOA you own your land
and you own the home you also own a
percentage of the common land and a
percentage of the open land that's
required by the planning board to remain
open in perpetuity and so any judgment
Against One homeowner could put the
entire Association on the
hook further discussion or
comments seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 617 if you are
in favor of the motion then you'll vote
Yes if you are opposed to that motion
you will vote no close clerk will call
the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
yes representative Alward yes the clerk
votes yes representative
France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes Representative
stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana no
representative Gerard
yes representative grun
no Madam chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of
11-7 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 617 is ought to pass with
amendment that will go on the regular
calendar and
who will write the majority report I'll
write the majority report Madam chair
representative
Murphy and Minority
Report representative stavis thank
you and with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill 617
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 425 allowing tax
exempt entities to keep their tax exempt
status while renting facilities or
property to entities that share their
mission do I have a
motion Madam chair I'd like to make a
motion yes
represent um on HP
425 thank you do I have a second
representative Dolan seconds that
representative France would you like to
speak to your
motion is there any comments
representative Colby thank you madam
chair
um the addition of the additional
language um I understand that the
purpose uh was
to simplify and clarify and it seems to
do the opposite uh section B suggests
adding vague language to RSA
7223 uh which currently allows for tax
exempt religious organizations to rent
properties but here they're using using
terms like similar Mission or
um similar residential real estate and
those terms are overly broad they are
poorly defined and they just create
significant ambiguity and then down in
section c we're complicating matters
further by imposing excessive
requirements on organizations as well as
Municipal assessors who are not
certified public
accountants uh it fairly forces
assessors to evaluate an organization's
income and expenses in relation to the
law uh this could lead to dep uh
potential disputes placing unreasonable
burdens on assessors who may lack the
necessary time or expertise to perform
Financial assessments uh the additional
burdens coupled with overly broad
terminology are likely to result in more
confusion unequal application across
jurisdictions and would then worsen the
very problem this bill attempts to
correct
thank you further comments or discussion
representative
Davis thank you madam chair um I'd like
to also point out in section c of the
bill that there's a a
contradiction where uh in line 11 it a
that rents not more than one church
parsonage or similar residential real
estate and or not more than one worship
building and then at the end of that
paragraph in line 17 it says an
organization shall not claim more than
one exemption under this s subparagraph
when I read those two sentences together
I'm totally lost I don't understand what
that
means thank you further comments
discussion seeing none the motion before
is us is ought to pass on House Bill 4
25 if you are in favor of the motion
you'll vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
Alward
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative
Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative majori no
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana no no
representative Gerard no Representative
grund no madame chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 the committee recommendation on
House Bill 425
will be ought to pass and that will go
on the regular
calendar who will write the majority
report representative France and The
Minority Report representative Colby
thank
you and with that the chair will close
the executive session on House Bill 425
next the chair will open the executive
session on House Bill 421 FN relative to
notice of tax exempt status filing
procedures by Town officials or
offices do I have a motion
Madam chair I would like to uh move or
I'd like to recommend amendment
20253 54h to hb421 FN thank you is there
a second representative karinski mam
chair I'll second that thank you
representative majori would you like to
speak to your motion to accept the
amendment yes thank you very much um I
after speaking with the sponsor and
taking a significant amount of input
from uh from uh from one of our
assessors from the town of Hudson um I'm
afraid to name him I don't want to put
him on the spot to do that but he's
sitting here so he might throw something
at me if I do or don't uh anyway we took
some some good input on this to try to
find some language it it seemed like it
would be easier than it was but to try
to find some language that allows the
municipality and the tax exempt
organizations within that municipality
to work together to make sure that the
proper forms are sent and received
uh sent by the municipality and received
by the organization so the organization
can then respond in a timely fashion and
receive the exemption which then the
municipality can make sure that they're
qualified to receive and we think what
the amendment um has done what we
believe the amendment has done is it's
referenced that the municipality the
governing the municipality rather shall
send the proper forms according to
statute so we're not naming a specific
form in case that form should change uh
but stating where in the statute uh that
the municipality should look that those
couple of forms should be sent out in a
timely fashion um so that the
municipality can then consider but or
not a but and the uh that neither the
municipality nor the
organization uh shall be penalized if
there happens to be yet another oops
maybe it wasn't received on time maybe
it was sent on time but the mail was
slow and and it happened in return also
so so we want to make sure that they're
not penalized uh in that and as we spoke
before about a different Bill uh last
year House Bill 1055 was
passed um and that was in response to uh
charitable organizations that did not
get their forms in on time and there was
nothing in statute that allowed the
governing body the latitude to grant
them the exemp exemption nothing in
statute they had to be denied happened
in my own town the what this bill does
what house bill 421 does is it just says
Hey municipality organization work
together let's try to avoid that problem
from ever happening again we think that
the amendment does that um and does it
in a way that satisfies both organiz or
both organizations so I would hope that
you would pass the amendment and if I
said anything wrong jisho now will throw
something at me he is not good move on
thank you further
discussion seeing none the the mo oh I'm
sorry who who oh representative Walker I
do think the uh making the assessing
office send out mailers is an undue
burden to that office both in their
budget cost wise and the time to make
the mailers up I do think the underlying
problem with this whole law is why is it
you have to put these paperwork in
yearly why can't it be five years or t
two by annually having it to do it every
year seems dumb that's all I just have
to
say further
discussion oh represent a majority thank
you again um to my friend from Rochester
I I agree with you and would add that
when I was on the budget committee we
reviewed all of the tax exempt
organizations annually to make sure that
they were still qualified to be tax
exempt organizations under under their
Charter or whatever reasons so I think
you're you're both right but I would but
we may need to look at that a little bit
further to figure out a way so that we
don't have to continue to do this or I
don't disagree with you at all that
you're asking the community right now to
send out mail which is a burden to the
municipality so I don't I don't that's
that's not falling on Def years so thank
you further
comments okay seeing none the motion
before us is to accept Amendment
2025-the
Amendment you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to accepting the amendment then
you will vote no the clerk will call the
role
Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Elward
yes the clerk votes yes representative
France
yes representative karasinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker no
representative stavis
yes representative
Gilman
no representative majority
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative german
yes representative Gerard no
representative grund
yes Madam chair
yes the amendment is accepted with a
vote of 15 to3 do I have a further
motion
Madam chair I would like to move
otpa on House Bill 421 FN is there a
second representative kazinski Madam
chair I'll second that thank you
representative majori would you like to
speak to your motion uh the amendment uh
the
amendment the amendment speaks to the
bill so no thank
you is there any
discussion okay
seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 421
FN if you are in favor of that motion
you'll vote Yes if you are opposed to
that motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Elward yes clerk votes
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
no representative majori
yes representative frock yes
representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
no representative grund
yes madame chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of
16-2 the committee recommendation on
house Bill
421 will be ought to pass with
Amendment and that will go on the
consent calendar without
objection and representative majority
you'll write the
report will there be a minority minority
report
no you you want to okay
okay well
what
the
so I think we
I so I asked so I had asked if there was
any objection to the consent C I didn't
see
one yeah
so note to
S
myself so it will be on the consent
calendar correct with no Minority
Report okay so with that the executive
session on House Bill 421 is now
closed I shouldn't have
asked was trying to be
thorough okay next the chair will open
the executive session on House Bill 458
FN limiting local assistance to United
States citizens or permanent legal
residents do I have a motion
representative kazinski Madam chair I'll
make a motion to retain House Bill 458
is there a second Madame chair I like to
second that uh representative Murphy
seconds that representative Kinski would
you like to speak to your motion yes
this needs a
a lot of work
and it needs to be retained to be worked
on
later further comments on
that uh representative Dolan thank you
madam chair this was a case where uh the
neither the sponsor nor any co-sponsor
showed up uh and which put I believe
puts puts the committee at a severe
disadvantage to be able to elicit
information about the bill I think in
most cases when that situation arises we
ought to give strong consideration to an
itl motion however in this case I will
side with uh leadership and and support
the
retain further
comments representative
stavis thank you madam chair I continue
to think that when a sponsor doesn't
show up to present their bill or take
questions on their bill that it as my
colleague says puts this committee at a
severe disadvantage it also puts the
people in New Hampshire at a severe
disadvantage because they don't have the
opportunity to hear us ask questions on
their
behalf um so I I will support the retain
motion but I think in the future we
should have a conversation and a
discussion about what happens when
sponsors don't show because several
several of them have
not thank you representative stavis um
further
comments so I I I'll add a comment and
I'll support the motion to retain due to
the fact that we had another bill that
was similar to this and the thought is
perhaps we want to kind look at both of
them
together any other question I me
comments seeing none the most motion
before us is to
retain House Bill 458 FN if you're in
favor of that motion you'll vote Yes if
you are opposed you will vote no the
clerk will call the
role Vice chair McDonald yes
representative
Guthrie representative Dolan yes
representative Elward yes clerk vote Yes
representative France yes representative
Kosinski yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker yes representative
stavis
yes representative
Gilman
yes Representative majori
no representative frock
yes representative Colby no
representative Jana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund
no Madam chair
yes the motion to retain passes with a
vote of 13 to5 and there's no reports on
retain bills at this time so with that I
will close the executive session on
house Bell 458
FN so next I will open the executive
session on House Bill 782 FN expanding
property tax exemptions for certain
elderly and disabled persons raising
public awareness regarding tax credits
and exemptions and requiring an annual
report regarding the efficacy of the low
and moderate income homeowners property
tax relief
program do I have a
motion representative Gil
Gilman Gilman I was gonna say stavis I
don't why uh I would like to move an
expedient to legislate is there a second
Madame chair I like to second that thank
you representative Murphy seconds that
representative Gilman would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you madam
chair uh there are several problems with
this bill um particularly uh tying the
amount of the um exemption to the CPI I
believe takes away the um will of the
people who have already the uh enabling
power to set these um these amounts and
they should be asked not told what it's
going to be um it also binds future
selectman to that same CPI uh index that
again binds them uh to an unknown
number um let's see but wait there's
more the um the printing uh and Dr had
has a part to play in here with the
printing of uh posting a notice of
uh how it's worked or what what
paperwork you need to have and it's
really kind of vague
um what's the other one I had another
line in
here all right I'll come back to it if
anybody wants to speak I know I had
another reason thank
you further comments representative
stavis thank you madam chair and again I
miss the hearing for this bill but I
have a question about the definition of
efficacy uh I mean what in Heaven's name
does that mean in this context is it
quantity of tax exemptions granted is it
the benefit to the people who receive
the exemptions is it the I mean what
exactly does efficacy mean
representative Gilman yes that's the
part that I
forgot that lost my tip of my tip of my
tongue um yeah what is the definition of
e efficacy really is uh an important
part of um how valuable this tool may be
um we don't know and the prime sponsor
wasn't there to answer that question so
there you go
further
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 782 FN if you are in favor of that
motion you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to that motion you will vote no
clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes Clark votes
yes representative France
yes representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman yes represent
representative majori yes representative
frock
yes representative Colby yes
representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grundt yes Madam
chair
yes the motion passes with a vote of 18
to Z the committee recommendation on the
house bill 782 FN will be inexpedient to
legislate and without objection that
will go on to the house consent
calendar and representative Gilman will
you write the report thank
you and with that the chair will close
the executive session on House Bill 782
FN
and lastly the chair will open the
executive session on House Bill 547 FN
relative to County reimbursement of
funds do I have a motion representative
grund is recognized for a motion thank
you the motion I make is to to pass on
HB 547 thank you is there a second
representative Dolan yes I second that
representative Dolan seconds that
representative gr would you like to
speak to your motion sure I will be as
brief as possible um there was a diff a
split of 5050 before basically the covid
era from the federal government for
reimbursement of nursing homes uh during
the covid time period there was a change
in the split to 56.2% from the federal
government um and that difference of the
6.2% went to the state but was never
given back down to the counties the
counties are owed this money and it
would affect their tax rate as well so I
suggest ought to
pass further comments or
discussion seeing
none the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 547 FN if you are in
favor of that motion you'll vote Yes if
you are opposed to the motion you will
vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward yes clerk vote
Yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund yes madame
chair
yes so the the motion passes with a vote
of 18 to zero the committee
recommendation on House Bill 547 FN is
ought to pass and that will go on to the
house consent
calendar and representative grund would
you like to write the report thank you
and with that uh the chair will close
the executive session on House Bill 547
FN so that concludes our publicly
noticed business for today and as always
before we adjourn I have a few afternoon
announcements so as you may all know
that there is a house session scheduled
for this Thursday February 20th to begin
at 10 a.m.
the week of February
23d uh please hold Thursday February
27th open for hearings only we we will
have um hearings all day then the
following week of March 2nd please hold
Monday March 3D open for hearings and
executive
session are there any
questions uh represented majority did I
get my dates wrong again no
no I had from last week sorry I had from
last week and it could be certainly
could be me I always blame me first I
put in the 26th for hearing you're
saying the 27th so just to be
clear when I say scheduled that means
it's actually scheduled and it's been
publicly noticed when I say please
hold that means that that's tenative
because we share resource
and this is why we're in this room today
so um I did put in the request
yesterday um so that should be um being
that should be scheduled for the 27th
but that's what I put in and yes I did
when I was looking forward PRI in Prior
weeks I wasn't sure when where that was
going to land and I pick Thursday
because that gives us like a week that
gives us more than instead of putting it
at the head front of the
week no no
no does this is it better for me not to
say anything until it's actually
scheduled no seriously I'm trying to
give you guys a heads up Madam chair yes
what here oh over there okay all right I
have the 25th the 26 now the 27th what
dates are we talking about I'm I'm
trying to be very
um thorough and as I explain when I say
please hold that's just like pencil in
what is scheduled oh it's it's it hasn't
the 27th and to be
clear I sent in the
request and I don't know if it's
processed yet it should be it hasn't
been public did you all receive a notice
yet okay so we're pencil maybe I'm being
too specific but we're penciling in
Thursday the
27th I hope that there should be no
problem with the committee assistant
getting back to me saying yes you can
meet on the 27th there's a room for you
okay I'm
sorry so not the 26th no that correct
it's the 27th of Thursday that's what it
should be because I did put in that
request but it to be completely clear it
hasn't been officially noticed
yet sorry to be so
particular right Jim representative maor
look confused you're okay representative
look at the rest
Gilman can you repeat the the March date
because that that went right past me
while I was okay so I am looking ahead
and I'm saying pencil
in or hold I'm going to change my words
to pencil in I'm looking to have a
hearings and executive session on Monday
March 3rd okay and that's pencil in
because when I go to put in that request
they could say h there's no room for you
oh well can we talk offline yes
n and and yes that is corre did did we
get that email notice
yet okay and I do recall yes it is at 9:
because we have a lot of bills we have a
an aggressive schedule
so yes I do
what the 27th all right maybe I
shouldn't try
to
okay well I feel like I'm confusing some
people I'm trying to help
but when help gets confusing then I
question whether it's helpful or
not
okay so yes representative Dolan as I
Rec call we were starting on Thursday
February 27th at 9: because we have
quite a number of
bills I did not um I did not put in a
scheduling request
yet so I I don't
know it's either going to be 9: or
9:30 okay I'm sorry um any more
questions okay
see
mhm okay could you just hold for one
second for the
11 so representative stavis was asking
we where we where we are at with our six
bills plus this um non- gerine amendment
that we had to have a hearing on today
so as I said I have this massive master
schedule where I planned everything
ahead all through
crossover so I just discussed um our
plans for the 27th which is next week
and then thereafter we have one two
three five bills left so what I'm
looking at is on the 3D which is a
Monday that we will be hearing five
bills and then we will be having an
executive session after lunch so that
might be um a lot of bills and
then I'm looking at the 10th um to do an
executive session as well so we're
almost done with hearings and we just
have um after that a lot of bills to
exec um representative
Murphy just make sure you don't do the
11th because I will not be
here it's election day did I I just want
to make sure that's all okay thank you
um yes I'll note that that would be a
Tuesday or yeah that's correct or if I
you do have it I'll need a um um a
substitute thank you yeah so we we were
trying to we were trying to have our
meetings on Mondays but that doesn't
always work out as we all um see and I
was not looking at the 11th but thank
you for bringing that to my attention
I'm looking at the
10th
okay any other questions seeing none I
will adjourn the committee meeting for
today have a great weekend well well
we'll see you on Thursday and then have
a great weekend thank you you